Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff.
Ich begrüße alle hier zur Ausgabe 98 von UKW.
Und heute geht's natürlich wieder mal um die Ukraine. Diese Krise ist noch lange nicht durchgestanden und dementsprechend gibt's auch eine Menge zu berichten und das letzte Mal.
Wir, nämlich ich und Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Eine Sendung veröffentlicht am 5. Mai, ist schon wieder ein bisschen her, genau genommen zwei Wochen, heute ist der 19. Mai.
Wo wir das jetzt aufnehmen. Ja und jetzt wollen wir mal so ein bisschen äh zurückblicken, was denn eigentlich so passiert ist und wie sich die Gesamtsituation.
So darstellt und ja es äh auf der einen Seite ist eine Menge passiert und auf der anderen Seite ist auch ähm eigentlich gar nicht so viel passiert,
Denn im Wesentlichen, das kann man schon mal vorwegnehmen, ist die Situation sehr vergleichbar zu der.
Vor zwei Wochen und das ist natürlich aus der Perspektive der Ukraine gesehen kann man sagen eher eine gute Nachricht.
Ähm hast du denn european Song Contest geguckt? Den.
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Grand Prix, hast du das überhaupt schon mal in deinem Leben gemacht?
Ich habe das schon mal gelegentlich geguckt
aber ich halte es da so ein bisschen auch wie die Tschechen, die ja äh diesmal das seit langem wieder mit dabei waren. Ähm
aber ansonsten ähm eher fanden, dass das musikalisch so jetzt nicht gerade einen äh Ereignis ist, äh dem man allzu viel Aufmerksamkeit schenken müsste. Aber diesmal aber es ist natürlich immer ein Politikum, ja.
Ja also ich habe mir auch immer schon verschiedene Gedanken darüber gemacht. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich Entertainment und man könnte sagen, das ist belanglos. Ja? Ich meine, das ist ja immer leicht gesagt. Aber.
Und ähm da bin ich mir auch relativ sicher. Ich meine, es gibt wenn du mal überlegst, was.
Ist eigentlich äh an gesamt-europäischen, kulturellen Ereignissen so aufzuzählen. Da gibt es die Europameisterschaft im Fußball.
Und dann fällt dir noch irgendwas anderes ein, außer Eurovision.
Na ja ähm gut ein paar andere Sportarten äh so Eishockey zum Beispiel ist.
Eishockey interessiert in Italien kein Schwein.
Handball und so, aber ja.
Handball interessiert sowieso kein Schwein. Das ist einfach klar, das sind so Ereignisse, die finden statt, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass es so ein Straßenfeger ist, dass die Leute sagen, oh fuck, ich muss um 9 Uhr vorm Fernseher sitzen, weil gleich ist irgendwie Handballfinale.
Ja ja, das ist das ist war so allzu viel ja tatsächlich.
Halt auch nur der Sport und der Sport klar kann man sagen ist halt auch ein Wettbewerb, gar keine Frage. Aber ich finde halt, dass man dieser Veranstaltung kann man jetzt albern finden, die kann man doof finden und so weiter, aber sie ist da.
Sie hat's geschafft, eine enorme,
vergleichbare Aufmerksamkeit in den allermeisten Ländern äh zu erzeugen. Ich meine, wir schauen irgendwie 3hundert Millionen Leute dazu, ne? Das ist echt krass.
Früher gab's ja auch noch Spiele ohne Grenzen.
Ja, aber das war dann halt auch eher so ein deutsch-französisch äh äh deutsch-schweizerisches österreichisches Ding.
Weiß ich gar nicht ja.
Ja, gut, aber.
Von Tiers.
Kurz gesagt, es ist es ist äh so ein bisschen das nächste, was wir an so einem europäischen Kaminfeuer haben. So und ähm es ist halt auf der einen Seite.
Ne, immer dieser Anspruch.
Das muss ja Unterhaltung und Musik sollen ja alle zusammenbringen und deswegen ist es ja irgendwie unpolitisch. Aber was ist heutzutage schon unpolitisch oder was kann in der aktuellen Situation unpolitisch sein? Und jetzt war's natürlich.
Sehr interessant zu sehen, was so äh passiert und die Ukraine ist ja mit einem.
Akzeptablen ähm Beitrag in diese Veranstaltung eingestiegen. Das ist ihnen ja auch schon.
Gelungen, diese Veranstaltung zu gewinnen und generell finde ich irgendwie die Beiträge äh Osteuropas sowieso eigentlich immer die Interessanteren so. Immerhin ist das jetzt nicht mehr so eine Veranstaltung, wo.
Alle die ganze Zeit Englisch singen müssen.
Es auch mal so eine Zeit ist, man hat richtig gemerkt, so am Anfang hat sich jeder in seiner Landessprache gesungen. Dann alle alle mussten irgendwie Englisch machen und jetzt hast du so einen Mix von ein paar, die sich das irgendwie ja, die das dann in Englisch machen, wie zum Beispiel Tschechien,
oder die halt äh sagen äh fuck it äh ich singe jetzt hier irgendwie meinen eigenen nationalen Blues und das gefällt euch oder nicht irgendwie mir doch egal.
Und ja äh zeigt sich, dass auch diese Sachen,
einerseits sehr gut sind und andererseits auch durchaus seine Freunde finden so. Na ja und dann wird ja dann in zwei Teilen abgestimmt,
dann erstmal diese Jury vote, also das ist so quasi so das, was
man eben so kennt, ne, wo dann so die Länder aufgerufen werden und dann werden also die Zahlen verteilt und so weiter. Das ist alles ziemlich gestreamt worden, weil diese Veranstaltung so groß ist, so viele Teilnehmer hat und so viel sonstige Show-Elemente hat, dann wird dann.
Durchgehechelt. Auf jeden Fall hast du dann zur Halbzeit quasi so ein Zwischenergebnis.
Was ausschließlich sich aus Jurys äh zusammensitzt und weiß nicht, wie du deine Erfahrungen mit Jurys im Allgemeinen sind in deinem Leben, aber.
Ich habe so generell an an Jurys bei Awards.
So meine Zweifel, weil das sind immer solche kleinen Eco-Chambers, wo so ein paar äh Spezies drin sind, so die einfach.
Das was außerhalb dieser Kammer passiert nicht so richtig fühlen. Ergebnis war auf jeden Fall, dass nach diesem Ranking die Ukraine auf Platz 5 landete.
Und dann gibt's halt noch mal den zweiten Durchlauf, wo sie dann in der Reihenfolge der äh also der umgekehrten Reihenfolge der daraus resultierenden Platzierung dann den Ländern noch Punkte zuschlagen.
Dann eben aus diesem Publikumsvoting, was dann irgendwie über Telefon äh geht äh oder oder eine App.
Ähm wie das dann sozusagen kommt. Na ja und dann kam's halt wie es kommen musste. Die Ukraine hat sozusagen nahezu aus allen.
Teilnehmenden Ländern, also vierzig Länder sind es ja ähm mehr oder weniger die Maximalpunktzahl bekommen.
Was dann dazu führte, dass obwohl sie relativ abgeschlagen da aufm 5ten Platz äh rumgammelten, dann irgendwie weit in Führung gingen und die dann eben auch bis zum Schluss nicht mehr abgegeben haben. So tatata, Ukraine hat gewonnen mit ihrem Song und so weiter.
Schon bei der Performance hat äh der Hauptsänger dieser Band, dieses Karies Orchestra ganz am Schluss dann auch nochmal irgendwie so eine.
Hilfsbotschaft hinten rangehängt, ja so nach dem Motto unpolitische Veranstaltung, no more.
Ja hier safe Maryopol irgendwie und so weiter hilft der äh Ukraine danke. Und ähm das war's dann auch schon.
Dann haben sie halt äh gewonnen und das ist natürlich jetzt,
der Wirkung her glaube ich nicht zu unterschätzen. Also ich saß so ein bisschen da vor dem Fernseher und dachte mir so gut, wenn sie jetzt nicht gewinnen, dann kann man halt sagen ja ist ja nur ein Gesangswettbewerb, ja?
Das Lied ja nicht so geil aber diesmal war's dann eigentlich auch wirklich egal und äh ich fand das.
Wirkung her ziemlich überzeugend. Also das war so klares so ein Antisch äh Moment, so ein.
Ja wir wir supporten das jetzt einfach. Wir diskutieren jetzt auch nicht da drüber irgendwie, sondern wir machen das einfach. Es ist einfach vollkommen klar.
Wir einfach in dieser Situation da so die Reihen schließen über alle Länder hinweg und das fand ich dann doch einen sehr starken.
Moment. Sehenswert. Wer sich das nicht angeschaut hat, sollte sich vielleicht das Video anschauen. Ist auch in den Links äh was sie danach rausgehauen haben, was sie dann in den Trümmern der Ukraine, Butscher und äh anderen Orten gedreht haben.
Und ein Tag nach der Veranstaltung äh veröffentlicht haben.
Ja, also auch auch das professionell genutzt, diese Gelegenheit. Ähm.
Absolut. Absolut. Und natürlich äh jetzt so ja okay das machen wir dann äh nächstes Jahr machen wir das dann in Kiew ne, ist ja klar.
Na ja, überhaupt äh Selensky äh ist halt äh nach wie vor super professionell. Ähm.
Was ich jetzt nur so mitbekommen hatte, gibt ja mal, gibt also viele Interviews auch der Presse und da kam dann so ein bisschen auch CTR, was denn so
Ach so, das war in einer seiner Reden jetzt vor zwei Tagen oder so.
Erzielte er, was er so jetzt den den Tag und die Woche so was denn so auf seinem Arbeitsplan steht und so eine überraschende Geschichte war
eben auch dass er speziell äh jetzt auch Veranstaltungen macht
also einmal natürlich die vor den ganzen Parlamenten und und Abgeordneten und Senat also diese bespielte halt weiter und halt ist halt auch ein wichtiges Ziel.
Eben weiter im Gespräch zu bleiben, dass Ukraine nicht vergessen äh wird, aber äh was eben das Überraschende mal macht, dann halt auch äh lang extra Veranstaltungen, wo er dann äh zum Beispiel speziell äh,
Afrika und Asien adressiert, ja. Ähm so wo man dann auch erstmal.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht das, was wo man jetzt aufn im ersten Moment glauben würde, dass ich einen Präsident, der sich im Krieg befindet, sagen auch noch darum kümmert,
eben um wirklich andere Teile der Welt, aus denen die Unterstützung jetzt, äh sag mal, vielleicht.
Zu wünschen übrig lässt oder äh ja, die nicht so eigentlich in unserem Fokus äh stehen, aber wo er dann eben sehr wohl auch drauf achtet oder
nicht seine Berater drauf achten äh wirklich äh nicht nur mit dem Westen zu kommunizieren, sondern wirklich mit der ganzen Welt.
Das fand ich bemerkenswert.
Ja, also er ist ja auch gut beraten ähm Afrika anzusprechen, weil natürlich Afrika einerseits extrem.
Betroffen sein wird von dieser Weizenkrise, auf der anderen Seite Russland und natürlich vor allem auch China, dort einen großen Einfluss haben und so ein bisschen still halten.
Um dann sozusagen ihre Partner nicht zu gefährden und ich denke, er ist dort äh auch unterwegs, um sozusagen einen ja einen Widerstand gegebenenfalls zu brechen und dort andere.
Andere Allianzen noch aufzuziehen, was also im einzelnen Ford kann ich natürlich nicht sagen. Wenn du sagst, er wendet sich an Asien, welchen Asienteil meinst du?
Was hast du da mitbekommen?
Er sagte nur irgendwie.
Asien äh die machen da halt auch irgendeinen politisches Treffen äh so asiatischer äh Länder oder Diplomaten oder wie auch immer. Äh also wo er dann.
Asien. Asien vielleicht.
Ja äh möglich äh jedenfalls also genau äh welche bei bei welchem Event äh das habe ich mir jetzt nicht nicht gemerkt
glaube ich auch auch so nicht gesagt, aber,
ja erwähnte das soeben nebenbei, dass er da auch dann über Videoschalte bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung äh wo dann wiederum asiatische ja Politiker und,
äh sonstige Leute sich versammelt haben und er dort.
Auch speziell die adressiert und was wir auch festgestellt haben, dass er sich auch sehr viel Mühe gibt, dann,
dass ihr nicht überall dasselbe erzählt äh sondern äh jeweils schon sich auch sehr gut überlegt ähm so in welchen historischen Kontext er das Ganze dann dann jeweils.
Haben wir ja schon in Europa, in Amerika gesehen, ne, dass er hier irgendwie in Deutschland dann von der Mauer gesprochen hat, dass er
in Großbritannien äh so Churchill zitiert hat in Frankreich äh weiß ich grad nicht mehr, aber war auf jeden Fall auch immer immer sehr spezifisch, ne, auch auch in den USA und hat halt da äh.
Klug argumentiert, ob das dann immer so ankam, weiß ich nicht, aber seine seine Ausführungen sind auf jeden Fall immer interessant. Also er hat auf jeden Fall da eine interessante Weite.
Asien ist natürlich sehr interessant, ne? Also dort Allianz zu bekommen, weil einerseits ist es natürlich auch der Teil der Welt der, sagen wir mal hätte kaum weiter weg sein können vom Geschehen.
Und wo aber auch äh natürlich dieser ganze Machtkonflikt mit ähm.
China mit reinspielt und ähm Länder wie Indien, ne, die halten sich ja derzeit ohnehin,
zurück, weil die halt einfach sich weder
ja jeder weder von China noch von von von den Amerikanern groß äh was reinreden lassen wollen, aber auch natürlich auch entsprechende Abhängigkeiten hat. Wirtschaftliche Ab,
von Amerikaner auf der einen Seite militärische Abhängigkeiten von Russen auf der anderen Seite indisches Militär besteht so im Wesentlichen aus russischer
Militärtechnik, also ähm das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant, wie er aus der Ukraine heraus.
So die Weltpolitik adressiert und da einfach auch überhaupt keinerlei Zurückhaltung kennt.
Und was in dem Zusammenhang ja noch noch einfällt, was ich auch äh gehört habe, was ich ganz interessant fand, ist, dass im Zusammenhang jetzt mit dem Ukraine-Konflikt der Westen.
Gar nicht so eine geographische Bezeichnung.
Ist äh und das ist auch nicht nur jetzt die NATO ist, sondern äh wenn man sagen, der Westen sagt, dann geht es eben eigentlich um eine bestimmte
alt, ähm der
Administration eines Staates, ja. Äh nämlich äh im im Grunde genommen, ja
westlicher, wo nicht nur westlicher Liberalismus, sondern halt
eben einen einen etwas einen komplexeres äh demokratisches Gemeinwesen mit dem entsprechenden Feedback und entsprechenden Institutionen einfach vorhanden ist auch teilweise
fast unabhängig noch von jetzt anderen kulturellen Aspekten oder so, weil äh sozusagen zum Besten dann auch du äh,
letztlich dann Japan oder Südkorea oder Taiwan äh Australien und so weiter äh äh dann mitzählen kannst.
Die ja nun nicht wirklich im Westen liegen und das fand ich halt ganz, ganz bemerkenswert ähm noch, dass,
sagen, das ist nicht der Westen ist, beziehungsweise der Westen in dem Zusammenhang eben keine geografische.
Oder auch noch nicht mal eine allzu sehr eine kulturelle äh Bedeutung hat. Im Gegensatz jetzt Russland. Ja.
Lass uns mal auf die äh aktuelle Situation in der Ukraine äh kommen und zwar äh konkret jetzt erstmal auf die den Fortschritt des Krieges sozusagen, also den,
die militärische äh Situation, dass wir das mal eingetütet haben und dann wollen wir auf verschiedene Asp
äh der letzten zwei Wochen eingehen, die da so äh passiert sind. Ähm Vorfälle im Krieg einerseits, aber eben was auch so weltpolitisch sich daraus ergeben hat. Ähm NATO-Erweiterung et cetera.
Also ähm am Wichtigsten
ist ähm Play kommen wir erstmal zu den unwichtigen Sachen. Also wo es nix passiert so im Süden Krim
Angriff auf äh Odessa findet nach wie vor nicht statt und es gibt dort zwar immer wieder kleine Scharmützel und ein bisschen hin und her, aber im Wesentlichen
passiert da nicht sehr viel. Ähm sie haben zwar sehr viel Truppen im Süden, aber kommen irgendwie nicht ausreichend äh voran oder wollen vielleicht auch nicht ausreichend voran
kommen, sondern sind erstmal nur darauf
bestimmt sozusagen ihre Stellung zu halten, das ist äh ohnehin so ein bisschen so ein Trend bei den äh russischen Truppen, dazu gleich noch mehr
Ähm aber das bindet natürlich dann auch entsprechend Personal der Ukraine. Das mag Teil der Strategie sein, wenn es denn,
überhaupt eine Strategie gibt. Also das betrifft jetzt den ganzen Süden, direkt oberhalb der Krim, also äh Jazz-Hon. Was nach wie vor besetzt ist und dann eben auch.
Die äh Region ein bisschen weiter im äh Osten, das ist dann vor allem.
Mögliche Vorstoß auf äh das ist ähm es gibt ja da so diesen,
Fluss, der da langfließt. Da ist ja nochmal so ein größere
Ausdehnung, wo äh auf der Südseite dieses äh Kernkraftwerk ist, was die Russen ja schon lange ähm eingenommen haben, aber dort müssten sie quasi rechts vorbei an diesem riesigen Wassergebiet um so nach äh.
Ja in in die Mitte des Landes vorzustoßen und das gelingt ihnen an dieser Stelle äh einfach gar nicht. Also diese ganze Frontlinie ist weitgehend unverändert geblieben in den letzten zwei Wochen. Abgesehen von so ein bisschen hin und her. Wenn man dann noch weiter nach Osten.
Was sich hier nach wie vor sehr bemerkenswert finde ist, der Frontverlauf läuft ja auch unmittelbar an der schon seit zwanzig.
Fuffzehn oder so besetzten Stadt Donezk vorbei.
Ja und wenn man sich das mal anschaut, das ist also wirklich krass. Diese Frontlinie verläuft sozusagen unmittelbar an dieser Stadt vorbei. Also dass Russland auch nicht gelungen mit einer ganzen Stadt im Rücken in irgendeiner Form.
Ukraine dort äh ins Land zu drücken, trotz ihrer sogenannten Offensive.
Diese Frontlinie läuft zum Beispiel auch direkt an diesem Flughafen vorbei und ähm
Allerdings gibt es jetzt Berichte, dass das ein wenig aufgerissen ist. Also da haben jetzt die Russen wohl Fortschritte gemacht. Das kann man allein schon daran sehen, dass so ein Ort, der direkt an Donnitz
grenzt. Unter anderem mal wieder so ein Staudamm gesprengt hat. Das äh hatten wir ja auch schon beim Kampf um Kiew gesehen.
Die Ukraine sich dieses Mittels äh bedient hat, weil sie damit eben bestimmte Bereiche überflutet hat, die dann einfach für einen Panzer,
Vormarsch, unbrauchbar geworden ist, weil es einfach nur noch Matsch ist und wie gut die russischen Panzer im Matsch funktionieren. Das äh haben wir ja schon mehrfach gesehen.
Wenn man dann ein bisschen weiter nach Norden den Frontverlauf, also sozusagen wirklich da den den östlichsten Punkt das ist so der Kern,
der ganzen ähm Aktivität beziehungsweise das ist das, wo diese ja diese Einkesselung versucht wurde. Also der Kampf um,
was so ein bisschen das Zentrum des ukrainischen Widerstands da ist im Donbass und drumherum haben einfach die Russen versucht überall vorzustoßen. Das ist ihnen auch teilweise gelungen. Allerdings
sind diese Vorstöße auch immer wieder äh versickert. Das Hauptproblem äh in dieser Region ist, dass es dort einen Fluss zu überwinden gibt,
den ähm wie heißt er noch gleich ähm la la la ist der Siverski Donnes.
Netz und äh.
Zu dem werden wir gleich nochmal was äh erzählen, weil da gab's ja jetzt diesen kolossalen Fehl der russischen Armee,
dort äh voran zu ähm marschieren.
Äh einer Flussüberquerung und ähm aber grundsätzlich geht's nicht so richtig voran. Der heißeste Kampf ist derzeit äh der um die Stadt.
Cevero Donuts, das ist eigentlich so der das letzte Gebiet von Luhansk, was äh die Russen noch nicht eingenommen haben,
Und da ist es für die Ukraine ziemlich schwierig. Die leisten da viel Widerstand, aber haben nur das Problem, dass sie jetzt von drei Seiten von den Russen eingekesselt sind und ähm nach Westen hin, wo im Prinzip sie sicher zurückziehen äh könnten. Da liegt,
auch noch die ähm der Ort äh wie heißt das äh,
aber auch da fließt dieser Fluss durch und die Brücken sind irgendwie alle schon zerstört, also das,
nochmal eine schwierige Situation geben dort äh in dieser Stadt, aber bisher hält dieser Widerstand und ähm wir werden gleich noch viel darüber reden, wie das bei den Russen eigentlich gerade so militärisch aussieht.
Noch einen kurzen äh ein äh Wurf äh also Sever.
Geschrieben heißt halt in meisten islamischen Sprachen Norden das heißt Severo Donetsk ist quasi Norddonetzk.
Und der Civorski Donezk,
äh äh River oder so ist sozusagen der Nordfluss im Gegensatz zu dann, weiß ich nicht, dem unteren Donuts oder dem normalen Donezf Fluss,
nur äh sagen weiß man irgendwo irgendwas mit See wäre davor oder Sever äh äh liest, heißt das irgendwie Nord äh ja.
Ah ja. Übrigens, kleiner Hinweis, bei ähm Netflix gibt es jetzt die Serie Dinner des Volkes in allen drei Staffeln mit deutschen Untertiteln.
Äh ich hatte mir bisher nur auf Arte, die eine angeschaut und jetzt habe ich auch angefangen, die zweite Staffel äh zu sehen und äh russische äh Missverständnisse mit ähm,
Übertragung in die äh ukrainische Sprache äh insbesondere im Zusammenhang mit was heißt eigentlich Süden äh spielt in der ersten Folge schon eine große Rolle.
Das mal so als Spoiler,
äh dass ich keine Ahnung von slawischen Sprachen habe, habe ich ja ganz zu Beginn hier schon äh von mir gegeben. Okay, Runden wir mal kurz das militärische Gesamtbild äh ab. Last but not least ist natürlich der Erfolg der Ukraine im.
Nördlichen Ostteil rund um die Stadt Sharkiv, zweitgrößte Stadt äh der Ukraine äh zu nennen.
Dort ist es halt den ukrainischen Truppen gelungen, die Russen soweit zurückzudrängen, dass sie eben teilweise auch schon,
an die Grenze zu Russland sie zurückgedrückt haben noch nicht auf der gesamten Breite, aber zumindest in relevanten Maße, so dass halt jetzt in eigentlich so
in Anführungsstrichen normales Leben wieder möglich ist, also viele kehren auch in die Stadt zurück. Das ist natürlich auch gut.
Wenn so was möglich ist, ähm aber äh vor allem ist es einfach der Ukraine dort gelungen.
Einerseits einen Achtungserfolg zu erzielen und auch, sagen wir mal, für die Öffentlichkeit und die Motivation wichtigen Erfolg zu erzielen. Äh war ja, gab's ja diese Bilder von dieser Truppe, die dann wirklich mal an die Grenze vorgestoßen sind und auch so ein Grenzposten aufgebaut haben.
Das macht sich immer gut. Aber es ist halt auch strategisch sehr interessant, weil was bedeutet denn das.
Dadurch, dass ich jetzt dort den Norden von Shakiw haben.
Erstmal den Druck von der Großstadt weg, aber sie drohen jetzt quasi auch, auch wenn das an der Stelle wegen Flussverläufen wieder sehr schwierig ist äh
nördlichen Ostbereich, also im Luhansk im Norden ähm in den Osten vorzudringen und das.
Bedeuten und bedeutet das vielleicht auch jetzt schon, dass sie eben einen wichtigen Versorgungsweg der Russen abschneiden.
Unter anderem aus der Stadt äh Belgorot.
Kommen und um von Birke Rott äh entsprechende Verstärkung, Munition et cetera ins Land zu bekommen, sind also die dort verlaufenden Straßen für die Russen sehr wichtig.
Nicht die einzige Versorgungslinie, die sie äh haben, aber es ist definitiv etwas, wo ähm ja, wo es schwierig ist und wenn die Russen da halt gegenhalten wollen, um das zu verhindern, was sie ja gerade versuchen, müssen sie dann wiederum auch äh,
Gruppen aus dem Kampfbereich in diesem Ostzentrum, was ich vorhin beschrieben habe, abziehen und das äh macht es für sie gerade strategisch sehr schwierig dagegen vorzugehen. Also insgesamt zeigt sich hier einfach wieder die Strategie,
Ukraine.
Die ähm ja immer gut darüber nachdenken, wo sie denn jetzt Stiche setzen und wo sie jetzt ihre ähm Gelegenheiten nutzen und das äh ist sozusagen hintenrum ein Versuch,
das ganze Kriegsgeschehen so ein bisschen zum Erliegen zu bringen. Also nicht, dass da keiner mehr kämpft, aber das ist sozusagen keine keine Landgewinne gibt und das ist eben die Gesamtsituation, die wir da jetzt eigentlich derzeit vorfinden und was sich so in den letzten zwei Wochen alles
ähm ja, passiert ist. Ähm.
Dann gibt's noch vielleicht zum Abschluss der des Überblicks die.
Hickhack um diese Schlangeninsel. Wir erinnern uns, ja äh Russian Warship äh damit fing ja irgendwie dieser Krieg gefühlt an und ähm da geht's echt hin und her. Also nachdem.
Die Ukraine, die Moskau versenkt hat und damit ja diese ganze Luftabwehr,
Sicherungen der Schwarzmeerflotte der Russen durcheinander gebracht hat, versuchen die Russen halt auf dieser Insel entsprechende.
Unterzubringen, also eine Luftabwehr zu installieren und das wird also permanent
der Ukraine wieder zurückgeschlagen. Ist gerade ein bisschen unklar, wie so der letzte Stand ist. Auf jeden Fall gibt's zahlreiche Videos, wo einfach äh die ukrainische,
Amie, mit Missalz, mit Drohnen, mit äh sogar mit mit äh Kampfjets über diese äh Insel zieht und.
Hubschrauber, die gerade Truppen
absetzen, zerstören, äh Miss Hals, die da schon stationiert sind, zerstören Boote, zerstören zahlreiche Lande äh Boote und äh Versorgungsboote. Also da geht's ähm wild zur Sache.
Man kann glaube ich festhalten
derzeit einen Angriff auf die Ukraine und speziell eben auf Odessa, auf dem Seeweg sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, weil einfach die Schwarzmeerflotte.
Paralysiert ist. Also die kann da einfach nicht viel machen. Die wissen, wenn sie sich dem Land zu sanieren, dann kommen die irgendwie mit ihren Neptunraketen.
Und hauen die weg, egal ob's jetzt noch welche gibt oder nicht, die Angst ist auf jeden Fall da, aber sie können halt auch mit Fighterjets und so weiter agieren und vor allem auch mit ihren Drohnen und den Russen scheint äh bisher nicht viel,
dazu eingefallen zu sein.
Auch auffällig ist, also zumindest erscheint es so, dass die
Ukrainische Luftwaffe jetzt wieder öfter zu sehen ist, also wie Gott sagte, sie haben sogar einen einen Angriff auf die Schlangeninsel geflogen mit äh Kampfjets.
Aber auch ansonsten äh hat man halt jetzt öfter.
Videos äh von ukrainischen Kampfflugzeugen an der Front gesehen, wo sie halt äh Luftunterstützung für Bodentruppen
leisten, so das war also wochenlang war die ukrainische Luftwaffe so ein bisschen auch äh abwesend beziehungsweise hat halt.
Nach Expertenmeinungen so etwa um die fünf
Einsätze am Tag äh nur geflogen, während die Russen so ungefähr auf 1hundert Einsätze kamen, aber ähm
Ja, das scheint sich halt halt auch ein bisschen zu wandeln und die Russen verlieren nach wie vor äh holen teilweise wirklich ihre teuersten und besten Kampfflugzeuge, die sie da im Einsatz
haben so mit immer noch einer beunruhigenden, also aus russischer Sicht beunruhigenden Rate.
Ja. Ja ähm,
vielleicht noch ein, zwei Anmerkungen zu Mario Pool und Transnistrien. Also Mario Pohl, da gibt's ja immer noch diesen äh Restkampf, der äh Asuftruppen, die in diesem Azupfstahl
Stahlwerk ähm in diesem Tunnelsystem,
sich verschanzt haben. Da haben die Russen nicht aufgehört, die ganze Zeit anzugreifen. Jetzt grad gestern gab's eine
Evakuierung von verletzten Soldaten und das ist ein bisschen unklar, ich weiß nicht, was du da jetzt zuletzt rausgehört hast
ob jetzt noch Soldaten da sind. Ich habe gelesen, es sind noch 1.000 bis 1500 Soldaten vor Ort, also dass der Kampf da nicht komplett beendet ist. Äh an anderen Stellen hieß es, es sei komplett evakuiert, also.
Nicht so sicher.
Also meine Information ist, äh dass äh sie jetzt offiziell zumindest äh äh komplett
evakuiert haben. Also ich sehe zumindest auch in dem aktuellen Frontverlauf.
Frontverlaufs äh Bildern war um Marriopol sonst immer noch so ein kleines
so so ein Stückchen Front, aber äh das scheint jetzt nicht mehr äh da zu sein. Insofern ja ist noch ein bisschen unklar.
Ich hatte noch überlegt.
Du hast recht. Ja genau hm.
Ich hatte noch äh überlegt auch.
Nicht vielleicht auch der eine oder andere Kämpfer, ne mal versucht haben wird äh einfach äh ja durchzusickern irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung, auf eigene Faust äh zu versuchen, äh da rauszukommen, aber
ich werden bestimmt einige auch gemacht haben oder sich versuchen dort sich irgendwie solange zu verstecken und dann unters Volk zu mischen, keine Ahnung äh,
aber der Großteil scheint jetzt in sich in russischer Hand zu befinden und es wohl wohl länger auch darüber verhandelt.
Äh welche Art von ja Aufsicht äh also unter welcher Aufsicht diese Kapitulation dann stattfindet und letzte, was ich noch gehört hatte, war, dass die Amerikaner besorgt sein über
äh die Behandlung äh dieser Gefangenen, also dass die Russen da auch äh,
Ja äh sich sich eben im Rahmen.
Ähm der internationalen äh Gepflogenheiten äh äh verhalten, wobei äh sie jetzt auch die Nummer fahren, dass sie meinen, äh sie werden jetzt gucken äh wer denn von diesen Leuten jetzt auch
irgendwelche Kriegsverbrechen begangen hat und dann äh ja.
Quasi als ja reziprok zu dann
jetzt den den äh Prozessen gegen Kriegsverbrecher in der Ukraine dann auch eigene Prozesse gegen ukrainische Kriegsverbrecher.
Na klar.
Äh zu machen.
Ja, okay. Also,
paar möglichen Partisanenkrieg äh sagen wir nachher noch was. Vielleicht als allerletztes äh Transnistrien sieht nicht so aus, als ob das noch in irgendeiner Form nennenswert eingreift. Da gibt's halt immer mal wieder so ein bisschen Droherei.
Aber das scheint äh.
So wie es derzeit aussieht wird äh Transnisschen erstmal keine äh Rolle spielen in diesem ganzen Konflikt.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal auf diesen Fall mit dem gescheiterten Flussübertritt ähm.
Bei ähm wie hieß dieser Ort noch gleich, Bill.
Ja, da kommen sie wieder hier, meine meine Ortskenntnisse, aber ich äh kriege hier alles nachgeschlagen. Kein Problem. Der Ort.
Heißt der, genau. Und der von mir vorhin erwähnte.
Norddonez, Fluss. Ähm ja, das ist ein.
Ähm ja so ein Fluss, der sich um so ein äh,
größeres Waldgebiet äh herumrankt, unter äh fleißig vor sich hinfließt. Und die Russen haben an verschiedenen Stellen versucht da einen Übertritt zu machen, weil das ist sozusagen das Problem. Sie kommen halt einfach in diese angrenzende Land nicht äh.
Durch, weil Fluss ist halt mal nicht so eben über äh Treten, weil alle Brücken sind natürlich gesprengt.
Und so probieren sie also mit Ponton-Brücken, wie das immer wieder zu machen. Diesen einen Vorstoß, den haben sich die Ukrainer wohl so richtig gut ausgeguckt und es gab dann halt einfach eine Niederschlagung, ich glaube, es gab insgesamt sechs versuchte
Flussübertritte innerhalb kürzester Zeit und äh mindestens einer davon ist so richtig total gescheitert
dass sie halt irgendwie irgendwas in der Größenordnung einer eines gesamten Bataillons ähm verloren haben. Also,
am Anfang war von bis zu 1500 Toten die Rede später dann nur noch von 500 oder vielleicht auch nur die Hälfte von diesen 1.500 zu genau weiß es keiner aber es gibt
beeindruckende Luftbilder von wirklich so einem riesigen Feld, wo einfach ein Panzer in dem anderen äh niedergeknüppelt wurde.
Die Verluste müssen enorm gewesen sein.
73 Stück insgesamt äh wurden da äh also 73 Pieces of Equipment äh wie es so schön äh heißt, also im Prinzip Panzer, Kampfwagen, andere Fahrzeuge äh ja.
Sind dann übrig geblieben. Ich meine, was mich so ein bisschen wundert, ähm.
Eigentlich sind die meisten aber offenbar nicht alle äh äh russischen ähm.
Fahrzeuge, sage ich mal, sind eigentlich schwimmfähig. Äh also zumindest die äh der der Großteil der der Panzerkampfwagen und so und ähm,
deswegen haben die Russen eigentlich auch nicht so viele.
Jetzt weil offiziell soll ein Großteil der Fahrzeuge einfach durch die Flüsse durchschwimmen können.
Aber das machen sie wohl auch nicht so gerne aus äh diversen Gründen, obwohl sie's theoretisch könnten. Ähm scheint ihnen das jetzt auch nicht so richtig zu helfen bei der Flussüberquerung?
Ja. Ja, also das ist äh in der Tat ein echtes ähm Problem, dass sie einfach,
dass im zunehmendem Maße so ein bisschen das Equipment ausgeht für solche Spezialoperationen und es sehr gut sein kann, dass sie jetzt einfach äh zumindest an diesen Fronten, diese Flüsse alle nicht mehr überquert bekommen
sie einfach da genug.
Widerstand bekommen und einfach zu wenig Equipment haben. Sie haben natürlich an anderen Stellen diesen Übertritt schon längst gemacht, aber das ist natürlich auch weit entfernt von von den Gebieten, wo sie jetzt gerade drum kämpfen.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall war das mal wieder so ein Beispiel, wie gut auch die ukrainische Armee in der Lage ist, dann ihre Kräfte zusammenzuziehen. Also es gibt da so ein paar.
Äh Schilderung, wie das da gelaufen ist, wie schnell die da ihr Aufklärung gemacht haben und äh wie schnell sie dann da draufgehalten haben und die Russen waren einfach nicht in der Lage, sich zu verteidigen. Also sie scheinen auch einfach nicht mehr
Kräfte zu haben in ihren Bataillonsgruppen ähm um einfach ihre eigenen Maßnahmen abzusichern, weil so ein Flussübertritt ist halt,
schwierig. So das das dauert. Da brauchst du Schiffe,
Du brauchst erstmal diese Ponton-Brücken, du brauchst Schiffe, die diese Ponton-Brücken irgendwie in Stellung äh bringen. Du musst in irgendeiner Form äh natürlich das Ganze äh absichern.
Ja, wie machst du das in so einem Wald irgendwie und äh brauchst Techniker, ja und äh offensichtlich,
gehen halt auch diese Verluste, die sie so haben in zunehmendem Maße auch in dieses technische Personal um solche Sachen überhaupt noch.
Abrocken zu können, weil das kannst du nicht mit irgendwelchen Rekruten machen, die da das erste Mal in Panzer gesetzt wurden, die haben einfach von diesen ganzen Prozessen keine Ahnung und ähm dementsprechend verlieren sie langsam einfach diese Fähigkeit dort,
strategisch äh noch vorgehen zu können.
Ne, das das eigentliche Problem ist, wenn jetzt ich sage mal von
umgekehrter Seite oder wenn jetzt der Westen sage ich mal sowas machen würde äh sagen so eine so eine Überquerung an der Stelle.
Oder generell wenn du irgendwo vormarschierst aber speziell natürlich an so einer Stelle äh äh guckst du.
Natürlich machst du das zum einen mit Luftunterstützung und mit dann, ich sage mal jeder Menge, wie es schön heißt
Counter Artillerie, also sagen äh dass dass du halt dann auch Truppen hast, die wenn denn dich dann jemand angreift
dort, dass du dort auch wiederum dann zurückschlägst und zum Beispiel das Artilleriefeuer durch
äh gegen Feuer ähm ersetzt, weil es gibt halt sagen Artillerie Radar
wo du halt dann sehen kannst von wo der Gegner eigentlich schießt auf dem Radar und kannst dann wenn du gut bist halt dann deine eigene Artillerie
dann zurückschießen lassen und so halt dann entsprechend das Feuer unterdrücken oder deine Flugzeuge dahin schicken, um dann die
gegnerischen Stellungen äh während du den Fluss überquerst, gleichzeitig auch anzugreifen äh aus der Ferne und
die gegnerischen Truppen daran zu hindern, dich dann an dieser empfindlichen Stelle anzugreifen, aber offenbar äh diese kombinierte.
Kriegsführung äh scheint bei den Russen von Anfang an nicht funktioniert zu haben und funktioniert offenbar noch noch
immer nicht. Ja und so setzen die halt dann offenbar ja versuchen die dann halt Flussüberquerungen ohne dann den notwendigen Schutz zu haben durch.
Andere Truppen, damit das auch gut gehen kann und dann ja, haben die halt dann desaströses Ergebnis. So würde ich mir das erklären.
Sicherlich da mit reinspielt ist ja, dass sie halt auch einfach ähm viele Leute haben, die einfach sagen so.
Habe jetzt hier keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß, weil wenn du da einfach vertraglicher Soldat bist, kannst halt nur dann gezwungen werden, daran teilzunehmen, wenn du eben.
Ähm wenn halt Krieg ist und da halt jetzt immer noch kein offizieller Krieg ausgerufen wurde.
Jetzt diesen 9. Mai, wo alle das irgendwie gedacht haben, reden wir gleich nochmal drüber,
immer noch nicht stattgefunden hat, können die halt eigentlich im Prinzip jederzeit einfach nach Hause gehen und machen das halt voll auch im zunehmenden Maße, weil einfach so die Moral äh nicht so geil ist und auch dann sind natürlich solche schwierigen.
Militärischen Operationen einfach irgendwann auch nicht mehr durchführbar. Also es kann sehr gut sein, dass die Russen in nächster Zeit einfach diese Fähigkeit verlieren überhaupt noch Krieg zu führen.
Vielleicht nochmal ein Blick auf die allgemeine Strategie der Ukraine, die hat ja schon erwähnt, also wir haben diesen Vorschuss um Sharkiv äh gehabt, aber generell, wenn man sich eben anschaut, was sie eigentlich machen.
Ist wohl, dass sie äh nicht dort kämpfen, wo sie am wenigsten.
Kräfte haben. Also sie sind ja zahlenmäßig einfach teilweise den Russen immer noch unterliegen. Das mag sich demnächst ändern, aber.
Derzeit greifen Sie halt einfach die Russen immer da an, wo es am meisten wehtut und wo tut's am meisten weh? Bei der Logistik. Also sie gehen einfach auf.
Trucks und nicht äh Panzer, ne? Das ist sozusagen äh ganz interessant, also wenn man sich mal.
Anschaut. Es gibt hier habe ich auch verlinkt so ein schöne Aufstellung, wo sie mal äh geguckt haben, okay von allen.
Ähm Geräten Typen, also Fahrzeugtypen, die sie jetzt angegriffen haben, wo sind die höchsten äh Verluste bei den Russen? Und ähm.
Aufgeteilt in äh Flugzeuge, äh anti-R, also Flugzeugabwehr,
Armutwickel, also Panzer, äh Infanterie, Truppentransporter,
Logistikfahrzeuge, also äh Trucks und irgendwie äh so und die die Verluste der Russen sind so in in allen diesen Kategorien werden,
in der Aufstellung so zwischen drei und äh fünf Prozent irgendwie eingeschätzt äh
und also von von dem, was zerstört wurde, machen die anderen irgendwie so drei bis fünf Prozent aus und dieser Logistikbereich macht irgendwie über äh 16 Prozent aus und ähm das bedeutet, sie greifen also vor allem
Trucks an. Also wenn sie können, gehen sie auf Trucks. Warum? Weil Trucks transportieren,
Versorgung, transportieren, Munition, Trucks transportieren, vielleicht auch Personal, alles mögliche, ohne Trucks.
Kriegst du einfach diesen Krieg nicht organisiert und dementsprechend ist es sehr viel einfacher auf ungeschützte Fahrzeuge zu gehen.
Die äh wegzukloppen und damit einfach die Möglichkeit der Russen zu begrenzen in irgendeiner Form ihre ganze Logistik,
laufen äh zu hauen, ne. Kurzer Nachtrag noch zu den in von mir genannten Zahlen,
meinte natürlich nicht Prozent, sondern das ist ein Verhältnis zwischen Verluste der Ukraine im Verhältnis zu äh Verluste der
Russen und generell schaffen's die Ukrainer halt drei bis äh fünfmal so viel von Panzern, Anti R et cetera, all diesen ganzen Kategorien wegzuhauen, aber sie schaffen's halt 5zehn bis sechzehn Mal so viel.
Trucks wegzuhauen als die Russen wiederum die Ukrainern äh Equipment zerstört. Also daran kann man äh ganz gut diesen Fokus äh,
sehen. Na ja, also ist auf jeden Fall ganz interessant und äh es gibt auch neue Einschätzungen dadrüber, wie es denn nun eigentlich äh aussieht bei den äh Russen und ich glaube die.
Äh das britische äh Verteidigungsministerium hat so die Einschätzung ähm gemacht, dass sie einfach schon.
War das für eine Zahl äh.
Mir ein ein Drittel der Kampfkraft habe ich gehört, äh so 35 Prozent der Kampfkraft,
ähm so. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass jetzt 35 Prozent sagen, manche haben daraus gemacht, 35 Prozent äh
der Truppen wurden getötet, also äh so viel ist es ist es nicht, aber sagen
ähm quasi alles zusammen äh äh genommen, weil wenn du,
ich sage mal eine eine Einheit zu ich weiß nicht fünfzig, sechzig Prozent äh jetzt zerstört äh.
So Verluste hat, ähm dann ist eigentlich deine ganze Einheit erst mal dann weg. Ja, also die ist dann nicht mehr einsatz,
aus verschiedensten Gründen und wo muss die dann entweder wieder neu aufbauen oder.
Leute in andere Einheiten integrieren, aber das geht halt auch auch so schnell nicht und äh insofern ja eine Schätzung ist ungefähr ein Drittel,
lang ihrer Kampfkraft andere Schätzungen gehen sogar bis 45 oder 50 Prozent
äh an an der Stelle. Ich weiß nur, dass es zumindest gewisse
Einheiten gab, also jetzt äh äh Bataillone, die teilweise zu achtzig, 90 Prozent
äh dann, ich sage mal, entmannt äh äh worden sind, äh nicht alle getötet, aber die wo dann die Hälfte einfach nach Hause gegangen ist und gesagt hat, äh nee, machen wir nicht mehr mit
und ungefähr ein Dritteläh dann getötet äh oder gefangen genommen äh wurde oder verletzt wurde und wo dann,
am Ende ja teilweise ja Kompanien, die mit irgendwie ähm ja.
8hundert nee Kompanien mit hundert Leuten, wo dann am Ende nur noch sechs übrig waren,
oder äh ja äh Bataillone, BTGs, die dann mit 120 Fahrzeugen angetreten sind und drei Tage später äh waren nur noch 30 davon
einsatzbereit und unklar, wie viele davon überhaupt zurückgekehrt sind, also von.
Manchen Bataillonen ist dann sagen wir noch eine einstellige Zahl an Fahrzeugen überhaupt.
Zurückgekehrt, das heißt du hast dann zwar noch einen Bataillon, wo aber die Hälfte der Leute äh haben halt unterwegs gesagt, nee, wir kämpfen nicht mehr und äh ja und das ganze Material äh ist ist weg.
Und du hast dann also damit fängst du dann auch nicht mehr viel an mit irgendwie.
Diesen, weiß ich nicht, äh dann am Ende 20 oder 30 Leuten, die dann vielleicht noch bereit wären, grundsätzlich noch noch zu kämpfen, äh aber ja.
Junge.
Wo mit eigentlich noch, ne? Also
das ist halt das Ding und vor allem geht ihnen halt auch einfach ein Großteil ihres sehr guten Equipments äh verloren und irgendwann haben sie halt einfach nur noch historische Panzer äh die natürlich äh keine Chance haben
dieser zunehmenden Asymmetrie der Waffenqualität, die sich dort jetzt äh einstellt, noch in irgendeiner Form zu überleben.
Gibt auch so ein paar russische Originaldokumente, die äh von den Ukrainern veröffentlicht wurden, wo sie so
ihre äh Panzerverluste in den ersten Tagen dokumentieren. Das ist also Material, was ja irgendwie aufm Feld
zurückgelassen haben und was äh veröffentlicht wurde. Ja das sind äh auch alles sehr große äh Zahlen. Das ist auf jeden Fall nennenswert.
Von 93 Panzern zum Beispiel in den ersten drei Wochen die Hälfte verloren. Äh so von einem ja äh jetzt das erste Panzerregimment äh zum Beispiel.
Ja, wenn man sich jetzt so fragt, äh wie machen die Ukraine das? Ähm.
Gibt's einige Hinweise. Ähm unter anderem.
Gab's hier diese diese Sim Roaming Map, die hast du ja sicherlich auch gesehen, ne.
Wirklich sehr interessant. Also ist ja so, dass die Russen ähm benutzen halt das ukrainische Mobilfunksystem. Und.
Offensichtlich so obsektechnisch, also.
Diskutiert ja immer da schon dadrum, dass man irgendwie Schülern vielleicht mal sein Telefon äh wegnehmen sollte in der Schule, das scheint ja nicht so besonders gut zu funktionieren. Bei Soldaten scheint es noch schlechter zu funktionieren. Auf jeden Fall sind diese Ru.
Alle irgendwie mit ihren eigenen Telefonen unterwegs und die sind natürlich eindeutig identifizierbar, weil sie quasi russische Telefonnummern haben und dann gibt's hier so eine schöne Heat.
Man sehen kann, wo die denn alle rumhängen und das ja, das äh ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes äh Bild,
um zu sehen, wo denn eigentlich so die Truppenkonzentrationen sind und wie stark diese Truppenkonzentration auch ist.
Ja, wobei am Anfang, also man muss natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen auf, weil am Anfang ähm.
War's schon so, dass den Leuten die Telefone weggenommen wurden, aber das muss irgendwann zum einen umgekehrt sein, zum anderen haben die Leute dann versucht sagen
in der Ukraine dann Telefonläden zu plündern äh und äh sich so dann irgendwie an ja Mobilfunk äh zu kommen
plus ja das die Soldaten dann irgendwann gesagt haben nee äh so wir wollen jetzt unsere Telefon oder wir kämpfen nicht mehr weiter ja keine Ahnung
Ähm ja, aber äh es ist natürlich halt auch super gefährlich. Also es ist halt kein eigentlich keine gute Idee auf der anderen Seite scheinen die Ukrainer auch alle Telefone zu benutzen, so.
Ja gut, aber es ist halt ihr Netz.
Mhm. Nee, trotzdem kannst du halt die dann schon mit dem entsprechenden Equipment kannst du halt Telefone einfach anpeilen und theoretisch dann schon auch Artillerie oder so ähm.
Auf diese Position lenken, aber das scheint bei den Russen dann auch nicht so.
Ähm üblich zu sein oder die haben vielleicht auch das Equipment dafür nicht in der notwendigen Menge, um das durchführen zu können.
Aber soweit ich weiß, ähm können an die Amerikaner sogar per Satellit äh im Prinzip so eine Map anfertigen, ja, die brauchen ja noch nicht mal ins Mobilfunknetz reinzugehen, sondern äh.
Quasi von von oben äh alles tun, aber die Russen ja scheinen diese Fähigkeit nicht zu haben.
Schauen wir doch einfach in dem Zusammenhang mal auf die Art und Weise, wie die Ukraine so Krieg führt. Ist nämlich ganz interessant. Warum die alle Smartphones dabei haben? Na ja, die benutzen die halt auch tatsächlich im Krieg.
Für ihre Einsätze. Ähm es gab hier einen schönen Bericht über eine Software, der heißt irgendwie äh GIS for Artillerie und ist ähm quasi so ein Softwaresystem, was so ähnlich funktioniert.
Wie man das so für Übertaxis verwendet. Ja, du bestellst hier irgendwo, möchtest gerne ein Taxi hier und hierhin haben?
Die Software sucht dann äh automatisch aus den gesamten real time Standorten der Taxis raus. Wir den jetzt am nächsten ist und dis patches sozusagen an die und sagt hier wer ist am nächsten dran? Willst du's haben?
Schlag jetzt zu, dann hast du den Auftrag und so etwas Ähnliches setzt die Ukraine ein für.
Ihre Militärtruppen. Mit anderen Worten, in so einem verteilten System.
Die quasi äh orten sie alle, kämpfenden Einheiten, wissen einfach wo die sind und wissen halt auch mit welchen Fähigkeiten die ausgestattet sind. Und wenn es jetzt irgendeine
Meldung gibt mit Panzer gesehen, fährt hier durch den Wald, das ist irgendwie die Geo-Position, dann wird über diese Software äh
quasi äh 0 Komma nix irgendeine Truppe, die in der Nähe ist, dispatcht, die dann da irgendwie auftauchen kann und dann auch
sofort die Zielkoordinaten hat und loslegen kann. Also wenn sie jetzt irgendwie durch eine Überwachung, was weiß ich, irgend so ein eingegrabener Panzer, irgendwo gesehen wurde und die haben mir halt diese genaue Koordinaten. Dann könnt ihr das zum Beispiel auch an ein Artillerie geschützt, was in der Nähe ist, gehen,
dann wird da einfach ein Windeseile diese ähm.
Geo-Koordinate einprogrammiert, wie auch immer sie dann ihre Zieleinstellung vornimmt, weiß ich nicht genau und äh ab geht es und es heißt hier.
Geschafft haben, quasi so von Meldung bis Angriff diese Zeit irgendwie von 15 Minuten auf irgendwie bis zu 30 Sekunden runter zu bekommen.
Wirklich in der Lage sind sehr, sehr, sehr schnell zu reagieren und ähm ja, die Russen hassen das System.
Und vor allem weil die hm Kommunikation halt so über Satellit läuft und von daher schwierig in den Griff zu kriegen ist. Am Anfang, ich glaube wir hatten das hier auch mal erwähnt.
Am Anfang des Krieges gab's von äh russischer Seite aus einen Angriff auf diese Kommunikation mit diesem Sattkommen, Satellitennetzwerk.
Das war das, was sie sozusagen verwendet haben und dann kam ja Elon Musk und hat ähm fleißig Starlingschüsseln über der Ukraine niederregnen lassen.
Und das kommt jetzt wohl zu einem großen Teil auch zum Einsatz und das ist den Russen bisher noch nicht gelungen, dass in irgendeiner Form zu blockieren. Versucht haben sie's wohl.
Aber ein Darling hat da offensichtlich auch schnell reagiert und äh bisher äh haben sie da überhaupt nichts blockieren können.
Ja und das ist dann sozusagen äh der neue Weg, wie sie dort das pitchen und was vielleicht auch so eins der äh eine der Erklärungen ist, warum es so gut läuft.
Mit diesen ganzen Hinterhaltsangriffen, weil sie einfach schnell was gemeldet bekommen, dass schnell eben auch.
Truppen vor Ort übertragen bekommen und die dann eben teilweise mit äh.
Smartphones ausgestattet, was auch immer, ist jeder im Einzelnen äh verwenden. Einfach äh die notwendigen Informationen bekommen, Vorstoßen und dann eben auch gleich.
Angreifen.
Mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass in einer ganzen Reihe von ukrainischen Videos, wo Artilleriestellungen zu sehen sind. Man äh dort äh den den äh,
ja obersten Batteriechef äh oder so, dass dass die dort halt mit Handys oder Tablets,
sitzen ähm sehr häufig und dann direkt sich da irgendwie dran zu schaffen machen ähm jedes Mal, bevor es ans Schießen geht, also.
Ähm insofern ja bestätigt das so ein bisschen äh das das Ganze, wobei.
In dem zu dem Thema äh gab es auch ganz viele Leute, die sagten, das ist ja Quatsch, das kann gar nicht sein und das so läuft das doch gar nicht und und so. Also
Ähm ja, mein Eindruck ist ähm da ist was dran. Ähm so und dass die tatsächlich äh,
einen System dieser Art haben, wo sie,
was was ich auch im Einsatz befindet, wo sie sich drüber koordinieren, aber es dürfte auch nicht das Einzige sein äh äh worüber äh worauf sie sich verlassen, sondern die dürften auch ganz
Äh alle anderen Kommunikationsstrukturen über Melder bis hin äh zu ja anderen Funk äh Frequenzen und und so das Ganze äh auch.
Anfordern, ja.
Ja, aber generell scheint es auch so zu sein, dass einfach diese ganze real time intelligence den Russen da ordentlich äh,
zu schaffen macht, weil für so einen Angriff brauchst du einfach einen Überraschungsmoment und dieses Überraschungsmoment scheint einfach komplett raus zu sein, weil sie mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit überwacht werden.
Wenn die da irgendwelche Panzer äh irgendwo hinschicken
dann dann weiß die Ukraine das einfach auch schon vorher. Das heißt nicht, dass sie dann den Angriffen auch immer äh äh entsprechend was entgegensetzen können, aber wenn's halt diesen Überraschungseffekt,
dann sind sie natürlich ganz anders aufgestellt und dann ist das alles so ein bisschen so Hase und Igelmäßig hier, ne, so den Eindruck macht das, ne, also.
Wobei insgesamt auch aus den neueren Videos jetzt von russischer Seite hat man das Gefühl, dass sie teilweise,
auch versuchen jetzt die Ukrainer zu kopieren. Ähm es gibt wohl Leute an der Front, äh die sich jetzt auch zivile Drohnen haben schicken,
lassen, so von ihren Verwandten, ja
auf aus irgendwelchen Spenden und da gab's eben auch so einen aufgezeichneten Telefonanruf, die sind ja auch immer sehr, sehr interessant, wo sich dann
russischer Soldat dann darüber beklagte, dass sie jetzt auf Equipment Spenden von Schulkindern angewiesen sind an der Front, ja
äh der äh da einen totalen Rent äh abgelassen hat und.
Ähm es gab dann auch ein äh Video, wo äh auch die.
Russische Seite jetzt mit zivilen Drohnen versucht, Granaten abzuwerfen und.
Bemerkenswert war nur, dass die aus irgendwelchen Gründen diese Granate in
einen Trinkbecher äh vorher hineingetan hatten. Das sah ein bisschen komisch aus, den sie dann also sagen, Trinkbecher mit äh einer Granate und mit einem Faden äh dann an der Drohne befestigt.
Ja, also wie gesagt, die die Russen versuchen äh jetzt da auch.
Mit mit Selbsthilfe und äh zivilem Equipment jetzt es den Ukrainer nachzumachen teilweise.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie können sich
äh die Russen überhaupt noch verstärken. Wir hatten ja jetzt zur letzten Sendung, paar Tage vor dem 9ten. Mai hatten wir ja äh uns natürlich wie alle die Frage gestellt, okay was was kann nun Russland jetzt machen und ich glaube zum Thema Mobilisierung
im Wesentlichen zusammengefasst, so äh würden sie das tun wollen, wäre das eben für sie extrem schwierig. Auf der einen Seite
politischer Art, weil dann eben die Botschaft kommt mit okay, jetzt sind wir im Krieg und jetzt müsst ihr auch äh in Moskau und auch in Sankt Petersburg
Angst haben in diesen Krieg mit reingezogen zu werden, wo bisher ja die Rekrutierung eher aus anderen Landesteilen erfolgt oder zumindest äh im Wesentlichen.
Das äh natürlich Großteil auch des Sicherheitsapparates, der jetzt zur Unterdrückung der Bevölkerung dient, also die die russische Garde, äh da sind halt ein großer Anteil äh sind halt Reservisten.
Die eben auch früher mal in der Armee gedient haben und äh die dann auch alle
äh natürlich aktiviert würden zum großen Teil äh die im Moment, das ist auch noch ein Problem, dass das bei den Sicherheitsbehörden nicht gut,
ankäme.
Ja, weil das bedeutet halt so große äh Bewaffnungen von irgendwie gefrusteten Bürgern, die irgendwie überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf haben. Das ist einfach so das Rezept für Widerstand und Revolution und dann,
irgendwie alle auch noch über Moskau fahren, weil alle Wege führen irgendwie über Moskau. Das äh gefällt ihnen halt nicht, deswegen tun sie das eben auch nicht, aber der andere Grund ist der, dass eben auch Russland seine ganzen
sowjet Kapazitäten äh einer solchen Massenmobilisierung so einfach überhaupt nicht mehr im Betrieb hat. Also es gibt die Ausbildungsstätten nicht. Es gibt vor allem keine Ausbilder.
Einfach niemanden, wo du jetzt sagen könntest, so ja äh herzlich willkommen du äh
lieber Reservist so, schön, dass du da warst. Du warst ja schon mal vor 20 Jahren in der
so das ist jetzt das, was du hier tun sollst. Du musst ihnen ja irgendjemand auch was erzählen und denen fehlen einfach.
Offiziere, die diese Fähigkeit haben und die vor allem selber nicht im Einsatz sind. So und das ähm Problem der fehlenden Offiziere gibt's ja schon oft im Schlachtfeld,
schon paar Mal drüber gesprochen, weswegen sie ja so viele Generäle nach vorne schicken müssen, die dann auch noch weggehauen werden. Dementsprechend äh haben sie da einfach ein Ausbildungsproblem.
Den Berichten jetzt trauen darf, darf man natürlich nie. Läuft's eher auf so eine
schleichende Mobilisierung. Also sie machen das nicht so public, sondern sie äh versuchen einfach überall Leute zu rekrutieren und mit Geld versprechen und was weiß ich
ranzuholen und schätzen so die Kapazität vielleicht von 3 auf 30 bis 40.000 Soldaten,
die sie da noch irgendwie ähm nachlegen können. Aber das gilt natürlich dann für die, wie auch für alle, dass die einfach äh ja.
Teilweise motiviert sind, vor allem wenn sie dann vor Ort sehen in was für ein äh Zustand sich die ganze Kampagne äh befindet, aber dann eben auch einfach kaum Equipment haben. Also wir haben ja auch einfach nichts, was sie denen geben können.
Ja und die sozusagen die Töpfe auszukratzen äh jetzt überall an Personal und ähm.
An Material ähm ja das wird halt eben zunehmend schwieriger. Hm
Wobei man jetzt die russische Armee nicht ganz abschreiben äh äh kann, das soll man vielleicht auch dazu sagen und
äh nicht nicht alle Truppen äh waren jetzt in schwere Kämpfe verwickelt oder haben jetzt schwere Verluste erlitten. Es gab sicherlich auch Gegenden. Da war eher nicht so viel los, ja.
Äh oder Truppen, die dann eher dann das Hinterland so ein bisschen gesichert haben, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Russen jetzt schon am Ende wären
und ähm äh so an an bestimmten Material äh gibt es auch nach wie vor noch genug. Nur ja das das Grundproblem ist natürlich.
Das da werden wir später auch noch drauf kommen mh dass.
Diese neu ausgehobenen Truppen, wenn die mit veralteten Material in den Kampf geschickt werden und unzureichend äh ausgebildet eigentlich mehr Kanonenfutter sind als alles andere.
Und wir haben ja aus den anderen Zahlen vorhin von den Trucks äh auch schon gesehen.
Verluste im Gerätebereich liegen so bei drei zu eins und ich glaube man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass äh die Verluste im Personalbereich mindestens auch in diesem Verhältnis liegen. Dementsprechend,
brauchen Sie einfach auch noch sehr viel mehr Kampfkraft und das ist ein bisschen schwierig, all diese Zahlen, die wir jetzt über die letzten Wochen und Monate genannt haben und gehört haben, in irgendeiner Form zu tabulieren, aber nicht
Insgesamt ist da mal eine Truppe von 200.0000 angetreten. Sie haben mindestens 30 Prozent dieser äh
Kräfte verloren, wie sie sich dann im Einzelnen auf die einzelnen Segmente verteilt, ist nochmal eine andere Frage.
Und irgendwann erodiert einfach dein dein gesamter Apparat insbesondere, wenn du dann eben von der Ukraine auch permanent
von links nach rechts gejagt wirst und jetzt durch diese Initiative im Norden, durch diese Bedrohung des Abschnitts der Versorgungslinien auch wieder äh Truppen hin und her schicken muss und irgendwann
Deswegen kommen Sie ja auch nicht voran. Also es geht.
Kaum etwas äh voran und diese ganze Mobilisierung findet so nicht äh statt. Ich habe so ein schönes Video gesehen, da habe ich jetzt leider einen Link äh grad nicht mehr zur Hand, wo sie so eine Umfrage gemacht haben,
Auf der Straße ist ja immer nicht ganz so einfach solche Umfragen zu machen da haben sie so äh die Leute gefragt so das war glaube ich in Moskau.
Ja sind sie denn Patriot? Ja ja ich bin total Patriot also.
Was würden sie denn tun für Russland? Ja alles würde ich ja tun für Russland so, ne? Und dann so ah ist interessant. Ja, wir haben hier irgendwie eine Liste mit irgendwie freiwilligen Meldungen für den Krieg in der Ukraine irgendwie. Wollen Sie sie da vielleicht mal dann laufen die einfach.
Genau, wollen Sie mal Ihre Adresse hinterlassen? Zack war er weg, habe ich auch gesehen. Ja ja, das war wirklich gut, klar. Äh eigentlich wollte alles zu tun. Ja hier äh äh können sie sich freiwillig melden. Zack
wortlos umgedreht und äh äh.
Gegangen.
Ja, also das läuft nicht so äh gut und es gibt halt ähm gerade bei den Jüngeren da einfach auch nicht so viel Begeisterung, wie man sich äh durchaus vorstellen kann und äh
Vielleicht nochmal zu dieser Frage kommen, es brennt ja sehr viel in Russland gerade.
Also ist natürlich etwas schwer zu äh quantifizieren, aber das ist auch schwer, das in Relation zu setzen. Aber es gibt viele große Brände, die alle so ein bisschen den Eindruck machen, als zu leicht, außer Kontrolle geraten und man fragt sich natürlich, woran das liegt.
Naheliegend wäre natürlich zu denken, dass das jetzt alles äh Sabotageakte sind, aber das ist wahrscheinlich nur in den seltensten Fällen. Es gibt ja diese,
äh Cocktailangriffe auf Rekrutierungsstationen das scheint recht populär zu sein, da sind's schon mindestens so zehn Mal in Brand gesetzt worden einfach um zu verhindern, dass dort weitere Rekruten angeworben werden vermutlich.
Aber es gibt auch große Brände weit weg vom Kriegsgeschehen in Sibirien vor allem, wo ja die Russen offensichtlich Schwierigkeiten haben.
Dem,
Herr zu werden und es gibt die Vermutung, dass das unter anderem auch damit zu tun hat, dass sie einfach auch schon so viel Equipment aus allen Landesteilen abgezogen haben, um das im Krieg zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Denn generell ist Brandschutz und Arbeitsschutz äh so in Russland nun
Problem. Also ich habe Statistiken gesehen, wonach es irgendwie in Russland vier bis sechs Mal so häufig brennt äh pro,
Einwohner äh wie jetzt in westlichen Ländern und ähm mittlerweile hat sich aber auch der Rest des.
Blogs
eher Richtung, ich sage mal, westliche Brandquote äh bewegt, während sich in Russland irgendwie nix getan hat. So, da ist nix besser geworden mit mit Brandschutz, sondern im Gegenteil.
Und äh ja jetzt scheinen eben tatsächlich für die Großbrände, die wohl in Sibirien regelmäßig stattfinden, die sonst eine Armee bekämpft wurden.
Angeblich, äh ja, gibt es jetzt
zu wenig Militär dort was sich um die Brände kümmern könnte, weil es in der Ukraine ist. Ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne Geschichte
Äh aber ähm die Bilder so äh da glaube ich war schon krass froh,
einfach äh ja ein ganzes Stadtviertel abgebrannt ist und das sieht man sonst eher selten, ja.
Zu der Unterstützung des Krieges durch,
Westen und dort ähm abgesehen von allen politischen Flankierungen, standen natürlich vor allem die Waffenlieferungen so im Mittelpunkt und da ist mittlerweile eine Menge passiert, also insbesondere aus den USA äh
kommt wohl richtig viel Equipment.
Also da sind's gibt's Sichtungen von wirklich extremer Schiffs äh und Flugzeug äh Aktivität und ähm was halt klar ist, ist es vor allem diese neuen US-Haubitzen.
Nicht nur das Land erreicht haben, sondern auch definitiv bereits zum Großteil sogar auch im im Einsatz sind, dass es diese M.
777 Haubitze. Die halt ähm ja wie so ein Anhänger einfach.
Ihrem Rohr äh an hinten an den Truck rangehängt werden kann und dann kannst du mit dem Teil schon irgendwie durch die Gegend gurken, also schnell abgebaut, schnell aufgebaut,
hat es
Ding so zwei Schaufel, Füße, sodass wenn man das dann aufstellt so mit äh gräbt man das dann, gräbt sich das quasi selber in den Boden rein, umso fester es dort verankert ist, umso höhere Repetitionsraten kannst du da einstellen, weil du nicht immer so viel nachjustieren musst
Ja und das sind halt die Dinge, die extrem weit schießen können, also irgendwie so dreißig bis 40 Kilometer, je nach Munition hatten wir, glaube ich, ja hier auch schon mal.
Besprochen. Das ist also auf jeden Fall alles vor Ort, aber auch Deutschland hat jetzt ähm zugesagt.
Sie eben diese Panzerhaubitze 200 da hatten wir zuletzt davon.
Gesprochen, dass die Niederlande auf jeden Fall welche schicken will und dass die Deutschen das unterstützen und vor allem erlauben.
Mittlerweile ist auch klar, dass sie wohl auch nochmal sieben Stück aus ihrem Bestand auch nochmal schicken, jetzt nicht viel, aber immerhin. Ähm,
obwohl das wohl insgesamt alles so ein bisschen langsam ist. Äh zuletzt war ja noch die Rede von diesem Gepard Flugabwehrpanzern.
Die sind wohl noch nicht da, weil Munitionsprobleme.
Ja ja.
Das ist das mit der Munition, es ist wirklich so ein so ein Drama, weil ähm ich meine, die Kanone und die zugehörige Munition
stammt halt von Early Con Borle. Das gehört mittlerweile jetzt rein Metall, aber ist halt trotzdem in der Schweiz und die Schweiz wegen äh ja Neutralität hat jetzt gesagt, nee äh wir
die Munition nicht und geben auch nicht die Erlaubnis, die weiter zu exportieren. Es gibt jetzt wohl noch ein bisschen Munition.
Älter ist, die noch nicht äh irgendwie äh,
diesem Weiterexportverbot äh unterliegt und offensichtlich sichtlich die Kanonen und äh ähm ja Geparden wurden auch zu einer Zeit,
gefertigt, wo das noch nicht Thema war
aber äh ja im Moment sagt die Schweiz jedenfalls nö. Äh wir exportieren nicht, aber die Schweiz wäre natürlich nicht die Schweiz, wenn es nicht irgendwie eine kreative Lösung für das Problem gebe oder eine Hintertür und
äh sieht wohl dann so aus, dass die Schweiz aber die Munition in Einzelteilen exportieren
darf, weil dann unterliegt die halt nicht äh diesem äh Verbot und sie sie muss da nur anderswo endmontiert,
äh werden, ja,
aber das dauert natürlich wahrscheinlich auch dann sich zu überlegen, dass man dann irgendwie keine Ahnung, welche Maschinen für die Endmontage man jetzt irgendwo nach Deutschland oder sonst wohin schaffen muss.
Und muss jetzt so ein bisschen die Produktion halb verlagern oder so.
Und äh aber das dauert natürlich und so äh ja ist halt dieses ganze Gepard Thema ähm
ja kein kein Gutes, wobei die Dinger super nützlich wären, äh so da sind sich halt alle einig, also für die alle auch für den Einsatzzweck in der Ukraine und so äh
wäre es wirklich gut, die zu haben so. Auch wenn die halt superschwierig zu bedienen,
sein sollen, aber gut, super schwierig nach Bundeswehrstandard ist dann.
Ähm ja äh also weil kannst da jetzt nicht nur Akademiker äh als Artilleristen einsetzen, also insofern ist das jetzt alles erlernbar.
Und ähm ja wie gesagt, die machen die machen halt eine Menge Alarm äh die die Dinger, das sind halt.
Kanonen mit einer extrem hohen Feuerrate, die du nicht nur gegen Flugzeuge, sondern die du auch
Ziele und so einsetzen kannst und die halt auch direkt Feuer können und einfach,
richtig Verwüstung machen mit ihren 35 Millimeter äh Kanonen, zwei Stück davon äh und auch mit einer ziemlich hohen Feuerrate, das heißt ich glaube,
Äh die kann irgendwie.
Pro Rohr hier richtig sehe, irgendwie neunhundert Schuss pro Minute pro Rohr oder so, das heißt du hast da regnen dann irgendwie dreißig, 35 Millimetergeschosse pro Sekunde
äh irgendwo auf dich ein und das ist sehr unangenehm.
Ja, also die äh Amerikaner haben auch mal veröffentlicht in so einem Fact Sheet, was ihr eigentlich bisher alles so bereitgestellt haben.
Und ich muss sagen, das ist eine fette Liste. Ich weiß gar nicht, die kann man jetzt hier gar nicht komplett äh vorlesen, aber so die Größenordnungen sind irgendwie irre, also mal so äh eben.
Äh knapp 7tausend so Anti-Armoor äh Systemer und und dann nochmal 14.000 andere, also irgendwie sowas in der Größenordnung, 20tausend, so anti.
Anti-Panzersysteme
dann halt auch diese Switch-Blade-Dinger, äh diese Kamikaze Drohnen, die so irgendwie äh ne, so Leutring sind, also die halt äh eine Weile irgendwo rumhofern können und sich erstmal das
Geschehen anschauen und wenn sie dann was äh entdecken, dann Attacke mäßig auf so ein Ziel,
zufliegen können und das direkt zerstören, also quasi so eine fliegende Granate. Davon sind irgendwie 700 Dinger rausgegangen von diesen Haubitzen.
Sind halt irgendwie neunzig an die Ukraine gegangen äh auch mit irgendwie zweihunderttausend.
Ja 2hunderttausend äh aber vor allen Dingen auch 2und7 Zugfahrzeuge dafür, moder.
Und 200000 Artillerie äh Munition
und so weiter, ganz viel Fahrzeuge noch, kleinere äh Waffen, sehr viel äh Munition, aber dann vor allem auch so die,
Breite, ne? Also Lasergeile, ähm sind dabei und dann geht es hier, äh systems äh Optiks, Laser, Range Fires
halt irgendwie Zugriff auf kommerzielle Satelliten ähm Bilddaten
alles mögliche, Chemical by Logical Radio Logical Nuclear protective Equipment, also Medical zerplatzt, also.
Würful Monti, also die die Amerikaner liefern einfach so ein komplettes wir spielen Kriegsset
und ähm ja das regnet jetzt eben in zunehmendem Maße auf die Ukraine nieder im Rahmen eben dieses Vertrages, den sie ja jetzt auch nochmal,
bestätigt haben, mit anderen Worten, die kriegen jetzt erstmal alles und danach einigt man sich äh über den Preis.
Wobei ja, wobei Lendlis äh tatsächlich
fast mehr so eine PR-Nummer war, sicherlich auch wichtig, aber tatsächlich äh kommt bisher noch gar nicht zum
Einsatz, äh weil bisher die ganzen Lieferungen über direkte Autorisierungen gehen. Also im Moment kriegen die das quasi alles geschenkt
äh die ganzen Waffen. Das heißt, da ist nichts gelandet und nichts geliest.
Aber für den Fall, also es war ist nur für den Fall wichtig, dass in den USA jetzt irgendwie der Präsident vielleicht auf Widerstand stoßen könnte, dann könnte er von sich aus ohne Beteiligung jetzt irgendeines Parlaments über Lendlis weiter
Material liefern sagen ohne ja den Kongre.
Dass die Republikaner das verhindern können, ja.
So das ist äh äh aber wie gesagt ist mehr, war war mehr auch so ein symbolisches äh Ding.
Was potenziell für die Zukunft wichtig ist und einfach nur ein Signal setzt, okay auch der Kongress kann jetzt nichts dagegen machen, sondern äh lang der Präsident darf jetzt mehr oder weniger
selber liefern, äh so was er will und weil dann auch noch so, dass aber die Parlamente im Moment
sagen jedes Mal nochmal ein paar Milliarden oben drauf getan haben auf das was Biden gefordert hat, der heute irgendwie an 35 Milliarden haben und dann hat der Kongress mal eben gesagt, nee äh mach mal 42 draus so so
läuft das da
irgendwo gerade ab und natürlich kam dann jetzt auch die Debatte auf, die ja in Europa auch geführt wird, so oh Gott, da werden jetzt so viel Waffen geliefert, ähm entblößen wir damit,
jetzt nicht unsere Armee und wir was weiß ich, wir haben jetzt gar keine Stingers und Gervellins mehr zum Beispiel. So,
ja aber da muss man dann ganz klar sagen, das ist eine komplette unsinnige Diskussion beziehungsweise es halt.
Quatsch, weil also fängt man mal mit den Stingern an. So, Stinger ist halt wirklich alt. Die ist aus den achtziger Jahren.
Die meisten Teile, die da drin sind, werden nicht mehr gebaut so Elektronikchips und so weiter, also Stinger
äh es gibt da wohl eine ganz kleine Produktionslinie noch mit irgendwie Restteilen, aber im Grunde genommen kann man die gar nicht mehr so richtig nachbauen.
Und äh es gibt auch mittlerweile äh äh bessere Systeme, die denselben Zweck
erfüllen, ja. Also insofern kann man fast sagen, also wenn selbst wenn die USA all ihre Stinger
nicht nur die USA, sondern wenn alles Dinger dort verschossen werden, ist es jetzt auch überhaupt kein Problem und äh es gibt auch aber keinen guten Grund, warum man jetzt Stinger nachbauen sollte, ja.
So ähm,
Bei den Gervelins, die sind ein bisschen moderner, da sieht's anders aus. Da gibt's halt auch eine entsprechende äh Fertigung, aber ja auch da,
muss man äh sagen sind erstens die gut sind nicht das einzige die sind halt extrem teure Waffen und die sind vom Profil her, weil sie eben bis drei Kilometer äh Einsatz äh Reichweite gehen.
Ähm ist ja äh sollte man die ein bisschen sparsam einsetzen, beziehungsweise tatsächlich für den Zweck, für den sie eben gedacht sind und für,
kürzere Entfernungen gibt's halt deutlich billigere äh Waffen, die die Ukraine ja auch äh zu Massen im im Einsatz hat und grundsätzlich aber,
ist es so ähm dass ja alle Waffen, also die Ukrainer verfeuern die ja nicht,
einfach nur so, also was man in die Ukraine liefert, fällt ja nicht in ein schwarzes Loch und ist dann wirkungslos verschwunden, sondern ähm.
Die Waffen sind ja gebaut worden ursprünglich um in erster Linie natürlich Russland von einem Angriff abzuschrecken,
aber in zweiter Linie, falls es nicht gelingt, ähm russische,
Hat zu zerstören so und wenn wir die jetzt halt.
Alle in die Ukraine liefern wollen, dann werden die eigentlich bestimmungsgemäß eingesetzt dort, also.
Dafür eingesetzt, wofür sie gedacht waren äh plus äh dass selbst wenn damit jetzt,
die Fähigkeiten der westlichen Armeen
reduziert werden hier und und da, aber äh westlichen Armeen haben ja noch ganz andere Systeme und die ganze also der Großteil der Waffen, die da jetzt in der Ukraine geliefert wird, äh
hat der Westen eben jede Menge auch Ersatz für, um denselben taktischen Zweck damit äh zu
erreichen, aber selbst wenn man dort in der Ukraine alles verfeuern äh äh würde und sich quasi extrem entblößt ähm
wird ja gleichzeitig die Fähigkeit der Russen zum Angriff reduziert mit diesen Waffen.
Das heißt, äh ähm dass die Bedrohung äh dann in entsprechendem Maße auch
abnimmt von russischer Seite, dass man diese Waffen auch eigentlich gar nicht braucht erstmal, weil äh ja die schon dafür benutzt wurden äh die Panzer zu zerstören, die einen dann nicht mehr angreifen.
Jetzt voraus, dass es nur die Russen sind, die angreifen könnten, ne.
Ja, aber wir ja äh ja.
Theoretisch gäbe es dann auch China, aber ich glaube, das äh steht derzeit nicht auf dem Programm.
Aber äh auch da spielen halt dürfte halt wenn man jetzt.
Artillerie, also speziell auch europäische Systeme nicht die Rolle äh spielen. Wie gesagt und in und in Asien wären's eben auch ganz ganz andere äh Waffensysteme, um um die es dann ginge, vor allen Dingen
eben halt ja luftgestützte
Luft und siegestützte Waffensysteme, ja, die hier jetzt in der Ukraine äh nur eine untergeordnete Rolle spielen.
So, also insofern äh so die ganze Debatte um, oh mein Gott, äh dann hat die Bundeswehr ja nix mehr oder die amerikanische Armee nix mehr abgesehen davon, dass die Amerikaner so viel äh.
Haben äh dass das für eine ganze Weile äh Kriegsführung auch noch ausreicht.
Von daher ja.
Schauen wir mal ähm wie denn das alles so zum Einsatz gebracht werden könnte oder vielleicht auch schon zum Einsatz gebracht,
wird. Also auf der einen Seite diese ganzen,
Messers, die sind natürlich auch hervorragendes Futter, einerseits natürlich für die schon existierende Strategie im Sinne von kleine Einheiten, die durch den Wald marschieren, äh Angriffen äh sich entgegen.
Vielleicht von dieser Software gespatcht werden und dann einfach äh die Panzer vernichten. Aber natürlich auch für einen zukünftigen Partisanenkrieg insbesondere in so Gebieten wie Mariopol, die halt jetzt quasi militärisch gewonnen sind.
Aber wo es man immer noch davon ausgehen kann, hat sie ja vorhin auch schon gesagt, dass sie dann vielleicht dann doch ein paar durch die Tunnel irgendwohin entkommen sind und dort eben dann nochmal so
Untergrundkampf äh organisieren. Ähm es gab dann ein interessantes Video, was von einem chinesischen.
Fernsehteam gezeigt wurde und die Chinesen sind ja in diesem Krieg so ein bisschen die Journalists der Russen.
Ja, also nur die sind sozusagen im im russischen Teil unterwegs, abgesehen natürlich jetzt von russischen äh Journalisten und äh liefern quasi so die russische Seite so ein bisschen äh mit.
Oder gab's dann äh dieses eine Video, das wirst du auch gesehen haben, wo in so einem Ort ähm in der Nähe dieses Journalistenteams, als sie gerade ihre Kamera anhatten, irgendwie so einen Panzer auf einmal explodiert.
Offensichtlich durch einen Angriff, weil so ein Panzer explodiert in der Regel nicht einfach so.
Äh aus sich heraus, das kann man jetzt auch nicht komplett ausschließen, aber aus der Situation.
Lag es schon nahe, dass es sich hier in irgendeiner Form einer Angriff handelt. Waren jetzt zwei Sachen, die jetzt sehr,
Speziell waren an dieser Situation erstmal ist äh damit glaube ich so der aktuelle äh beobachtete Rekord,
wie hoch so ein russischer C 72 Panzer seinen Geschütztstrom abspringen kann, wurde definitiv gebrochen. Das Ding flog so
dermaßen in die Luft, das irgendwie auf diesem ukrainischen Meme-Account sofort aus diesem Video so ein Ding gemacht wurde, wo es danach irgendwie bei der ISS vorbeigeflogen ist?
Ähm das ist sozusagen das eine,
Das hat natürlich auch diese ganze Diskussion nochmal, das ist ja schon tausend Mal irgendwo diskutiert und besprochen worden. Ich glaube, wir haben das auch schon mal erwähnt, warum denn überhaupt diese Geschütztürme von diesen Panzern, diese Terrets
so krass wegfliegen, wenn sie denn dann explodieren und klar hatten wir auch schon immer erwähnt, ne, die haben ja dieses Ladekarussell und diese ganze Munition mehr oder weniger in diesem Innenbereich und wenn das halt explodiert.
Dann äh dann ist halt einfach äh Ende, ne, dann dann dann brennen die Dinger auf eine Art und Weise aus beziehungsweise explodieren einfach sofort, da ist dann einfach kein Überleben mehr möglich wieder das Gerät, sondern,
schon gar nicht des Personals. Jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass die so schlecht geschützt werden.
Tatsächlich, weil dieses Ladekarussell befindet sich halt unterhalb des Teams, aber es liegt da nicht so offen rum, sondern da ist dann auch noch mal so eine Schutzplatte drüber und das ist dann auch,
relativ sicher eigentlich zwischen diesen Panzerketten, äh munteren Bereich. Also da kommt man jetzt auch nicht so ohne Weiteres ran und auch so eine
Antitenk Miss Hall, die jetzt von oben einschlägt, würde das dann auch nicht unbedingt sofort äh.
Entzünden, stellt sie aber raus, dass halt dort unten eben nur so was in der Größenordnung von 23 von solchen Munitionen äh abgelegt werden kann. Das ist ja immer so eine Kombination aus.
Ähm die eigentliche Explosionsstoff um das Projekt rauszuhauen und dann eben die eigentlichen Projekte mit dem.
Einerseits die Explosion, um es zu verschicken und die andere Explosion, um zu zerstören, ne. Und,
diese russischen Panzer haben aber dann quasi im Innenraum auch nochmal an der Wand so Halterungen für die Ersatzmunition, das heißt um da nachzuladen, haben sie quasi nochmal ein zweites komplettes Set, was da einfach nur so an der Wand äh klebt und das geht natürlich dann als erstes hoch.
Aber das andere äh Besondere an diesem Abschuss war, wo er stattfand.
Weil das war jetzt nicht äh wie die allermeisten Videos, die man so gesehen hat, irgendwo direkt von der Front.
Sondern ähm das Ganze war ein äh kleines Örtchen in der Nähe von Mariopol,
sozusagen auf halber Strecke zwischen oder noch nicht mal halbe Strecken, ich glaube es war äh wie hieß der Ort.
Äh ich glaube war das.
Und das ist halt irgendwie keine zehn Kilometer von der russischen Grenze entfernt und ein Gebiet, was auch schon lange eingenommen ist.
Also was schon 20014 eingenommen wurde, was so ein bisschen eher Frontstadt war für den Kampf, für den Vorstoß nach Maryr Pohl, den.
Ukrainer ja bisher haben äh halten können bis es eben jetzt zu diesem aktuellen Krieg kam. Stellt man sich die Frage.
Warum bitte geht jetzt irgendwie ein russischer Panzer in die Luft mitten in einem längst eingenommenen Gebiet hunderte Kilometer entfernt von der Front.
Und da stellt sich halt schon die Frage, ob hier nicht so ein Partisankrieg schon in irgendeiner Form auch.
Äh begonnen hat und so kleinere äh Einheiten äh sozusagen auch im Hinterland bekämpfen und äh zunehmende Maße auch auf Infrastruktur oder eben mal auch so einzelne
hm Angriffsziele, die ihnen vor die Nase laufen gehen, ne? Oder ob dann nicht auch schon teilweise
die Haubitzen äh auch irgendwie zuschlagen, wobei das in diesem Fall glaube ich ausgeschlossen werden kann, weil das wäre so mal locker achtzig Kilometer von der Front äh entfernt und das schaffst du halt auch mit diesen aktuellen Haubitzen nicht.
So eine Sache wäre vielleicht noch äh lang zu den wegfliegenden Türmen äh zu sagen, wir machen das denn äh.
Westlichen Panzer beziehungsweise jetzt auch der neue Armata Kampf äh Panzer. Da ist es so, äh dass die Munition halt erstens getrennt
in einem Munitionsabteil gelagert wird und von dort aus dann äh befördert wird.
Und dieses Munitionsabteil ist auch mit sogenannten Blowout Panels ausgestattet, die dann dafür sorgen, dass wenn,
den Dortmund Treffer erfolgt und das Ganze explodiert, dass halt der Druck äh dann nach außen gehen kann. Da sind dann halt spezielle eben Panels, die dann wegfliegen können während bei den russischen T zweiundsiebzig, die auch noch mal
Ähm
ja sich dort erstmal der Druck aufbauen kann im im Innern, äh bevor dann so groß wird, dass dann ja äh der der der Turm äh
dann letztlich erst äh wegfliegt, aber äh dann schon extrem viel Druck sich aufgebaut hat und ja also wenn auch so was passiert, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwie.
Von
Leuten noch irgendeine Spur zu finden ist, die sich dann in dem Panzer noch befunden haben, wenn man sich teilweise die Wracks anguckt, die dann oft nicht mal mehr als Panzer zu erkennen
sind, äh sondern wo,
noch einzelne Blechteile eigentlich rumliegen und dir das irgendwie denken musst, was das denn vorher wohl war.
Puzzle.
Schon ziemlich schrecklich.
Ja, ziemlich schrecklich äh scheint es auch für die Russen äh zu laufen, was so ihre politischen Ziele mit diesem Krieg
betrifft. Äh es gab ja immer so die Ansage, ja die NATO, die erweitert sich ja hier die ganze Zeit äh vor unserer Nase. Da müssen wir ja mal was dagegen tun und deswegen mussten wir angreifen.
Ja und jetzt sieht's halt so aus, als ob ähm demnächst die NATO noch ein bisschen mehr Präsenz hat, als es den Russen eigentlich lieb sein kann, weil jetzt mittlerweile sowohl Finnland als auch Schweden einen Antrag gestellt haben auf NATO-Mitgliedschaft.
Ja, wie konnte das denn passieren? Ähm.
So ein bisschen unklar, wie es da jetzt politisch so weitergeht, weil die Türkei es für angemessen hält, äh diesen Vorstoß äh für sich politisch zu nutzen und.
Finnland und Schweden irgendwie Unterstützung von Terrororganisationen vorzuwerfen wollten die engagieren sich irgendwie für Kurdistan und das ist natürlich äh den Türken ein Dorn im Auge,
und machen da jetzt gerade einen auf Blockade. Ich kann mir zwar nicht vorstellen, dass die Türkei langfristig da.
Ähm sich quer stellen kann, weil das wird dann glaube ich irgendwann politisch auch sehr teuer, aber.
Um halt hier möglichst schnell zu einer Einigung zu kommen und zu einer schnellen Integration. Finnland und Schwedens denke ich mal werden sie schon in irgendeiner Form sich auf den einen oder anderen Kuhhandel einlassen mit der Türkei.
Wissen natürlich auch, dass sie für die NATO geopolitisch äh ein
themes Assets sind und jetzt nicht irgendwie anfangen, die die die Türkei aus der NATO zu schmeißen, deswegen.
Das Pudding kann übrigens überhaupt nicht verstehen, dass die Türkei in der NATO ist. Das ist eben völlig ein völliges Rätsel, wie das sein kann in seinem Weltbild äh so, weil ja.
Das.
Nicht der Einzige, der da Probleme hat, das zu verstehen. Da ist, ich weiß gar nicht, wann sind die überhaupt der NATO beigetreten?
A schon, die waren schon ziemlich früh mit dabei.
So also da war ja das das Thema.
Krise äh ging's ja um die amerikanischen,
in der Türkei ähm so, die dann ja heimlich.
Äh wegverhandelt wurden. Du dich erinnerst, dass ja.
Sagen ähm Russland damals äh dann zugesagt hat, seine Raketen von äh Kuba wieder zurückzuziehen, seine Atomraketen und ähm dann.
Dafür die Amerikaner dann aber heimlich äh sechs Monate später ihre Raketen aus äh der Türkei,
zurückgezogen haben, nur die Kurzstrecken, Atomraketen, aber offiziell eben ähm dass nichts damit zu tun hatte, dass es dann erst,
Jahrzehnte später äh rausgekommen, dass das sozusagen ein Geheimdeal war. Ähm.
Grade festgestellt, dass die Türkei länger in der NATO ist als Deutschland. Das wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Das war mir äh auch nicht so klar, aber ja ähm.
Ja also Gründungsmitglieder der NATO sind Belgien Dänemark Frankreich Island.
Italien, Kanada, Luxemburg, Niederlande, Norwegen, Portugal, UK und USA und dann kam zweiundfünfzig, Griechenland und Türkei zusammen.
Mit dazu und dann erst drei Jahre später Deutschland.
Ganz lange Zeit nichts und 82 kam dann Spanien dazu und äh ab 9undneunzig ging dann eben diese Osterweiterung los, erst mit Polen, Tschechien und Ungarn.
Zweitausendvier gab's dann den zweiten Schritt mit dem baltischen Staaten, Bulgarien, Rumänien, Slowakei, Slowenien und äh ja das war dann den Russen wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen zu eng.
Und äh Albanien, Kroatien sind auch beigetreten, Montenegro und Mazedonien, aber das ist ähm glaube ich erstmal nicht ganz so relevant und jetzt kommt halt,
Schweden und Finnland noch mit dazu. Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass das stattfinden wird, weil ich kann mir einfach nicht,
dass dann irgendeiner Form politisch möglich ist für die Türkei, das zu stoppen, aber sie werden halt irgendwas raushandeln für sich, wo sich alle wieder denken so, oh Mann, aber so funktioniert,
halt nun mal. Aber was würde denn das jetzt eigentlich bedeuten für Russland? Das ist nämlich echt interessant. Ähm das ist nämlich für Russland.
Schlimmer als es vielleicht auf den ersten Blick erscheint, denn.
Klar, die Grenze zwischen Finnland und,
Russland, die so lang und äh top sozusagen das, was es derzeit an NATO-Grenze.
Zu Russland gibt. Aber äh
effektiv vergrößert, die sich nicht nur um Faktor zwei, sondern eher um um um Faktor vier einfach weil ähm das für.
Russland halt auf mehreren Ebenen ein Problem darstellt.
Aber aus russischer Logik ähm.
Ich würde erstmal sagen grundsätzlich äh ist das kein Problem für Russland, weil Finnland oder die Nato hat jetzt nicht vor
Russland anzugreifen. So ja also
insofern aber das glauben die Russen halt nicht und deswegen hast du halt Recht, dass es auch so russischer Sicht sagen
wenn man glaubt, dass der Westen irgendwie vorhätte Russland anzugreifen oder es irgendwann zu einer Situation kommt, äh.
Dann äh ja in der Tat äh ist das ein Problem und ähm du wolltest aber jetzt glaube ich noch ein paar Gründe,
äh nennen äh was denn jetzt ich sage mal jetzt aus russischer Sicht, aus russischer Logik äh heraus eigentlich ähm ja das Problem für Russland.
Genau, weil also so rein jetzt Geo strategisch ergibt sich halt also nicht nur jetzt diese Grenze, sondern die Frage ist ja, was was was bewirkt eigentlich diese Grenze? Vor allem dadurch, dass Schweden dazukommt, wird die.
Aber auch Finnland wird die ganze Ostsee quasi so ein NATO-Leg. Und man muss halt sehen, Russland ist zwar ein großes Land.
Hat aber eigentlich kaum Zugang zu den Weltmeeren. Also der einzige wirklich unverbaubare Zugang zu den Weltmeeren ist der Pazifik.
Da haben sie halt äh hinten in ähm wie heißt das noch gleich, der große Hafen, den sie da haben.
Äh also auf jeden Fall den haben sie äh haben sie was. Es gibt noch ein paar andere,
aber sie haben halt einfach eine riesige Küstenlinie zum
Pazifik, da kann ihn einfach überhaupt gar keiner irgendwas äh verbauen. Das ist klar. Aber es sieht halt in Europa,
komplett anders aus und ihre einzigen Zugänge zum Mittelmeer und zum zum Atlantik sind sozusagen
ihre Basis, die sie in Syrien haben, einer der Gründe, warum sie Syrien so stark verteidigen. Das ist so quasi ja eigentlicher Zugang zum Mittelmeer,
dann haben sie halt das Schwarze Meer, aber da ist dann halt mit Griechenland und Türkei quasi diese Meerenge.
Da kommen sie irgendwie im Zweifelsfall nicht durch und jetzt ergibt sich quasi mit Schweden und Dänema,
dieselbe Kombination bei der Durchfahrt der Ostsee
äh auch schon äh Estland und Finnland im Prinzip, glaube ich, da gibt's dann auch irgendwie gar keine Lücke. Das heißt, ihr kompletter äh Atlantik oder Ostseehafen,
in Sankt Petersburg wird dadurch natürlich schon mal eingeschränkt. Andere Probleme ist, dass sie oben im Norden.
Ähm der der russisch-finnischen Region, da gibt's ja diese Halbinsel Kola und dort gibt's Momsk und das ist ja quasi so ihr Nuklear-U-Boot-Hafen.
Und dort haben sie quasi so ihre gesamte Flotte, mit der sie dann.
Oben durch die arktischen äh Gewässer Zugang zum Atlantik.
Haben. Abgesehen davon, dass das natürlich ein Riesenumweg ist, haben sie jetzt auch noch das Problem, dass sie durch äh das angrenzende Finnland quasi über eine breite Front über beschießbar wären.
Ja, also würde jetzt sozusagen Russland wirklich äh in irgendeiner Form eine kriegerische Aktivität über diesen Arktishafen.
Anstreben und wäre jetzt an Anbindung an das russische Festland
angewiesen, dann gibt's halt nur eine Straße und eine Eisenbahnlinie, die dort lang führt, aber die halt über eine Länge von irgendwie über 1000 Kilometer äh mehr oder weniger in Haubitzenreichweite äh wäre.
So, also das ist definitiv kein Zustand, den Russland toll findet.
Also im Grunde genommen ist die Gegend da oben für Russland nicht wirklich verteidigt ja also glaube ich weil äh ja.
Bestenfalls dann vielleicht aus der Luft versorgen könnten äh vielleicht noch von See, aber vom Landweg äh.
Wie das aussieht. Ja, vielleicht erscheint's wirklich nur eine Straße zu geben und eine Bahnlinie, wie du schon sagst, da ist da ist halt irgendwie nix.
Ja. Ähnlich ist es dann halt auch mit U-Booten, die irgendwie von Sankt Petersburg so durch die Ostsee wollen, also die gehen dann nicht mehr Anti-Taktik äh durch.
Das bedeutet auch, dass dadurch, dass ähm eben Schweden, wenn sie in der NATO sind, natürlich diese ganzen Movements auch meldet, die NATO immer äh up to date ist, was äh die Russen da sozusagen auch gerade durch die Gewässer schieben.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall alles nicht so schön aus der Perspektive von Russland, wie lange es jetzt äh dauer,
die NATO sich da jetzt wirklich erweitert, ist, glaube ich, derzeit noch nicht so richtig absehbar, aber ich vermute mal, da wird's äh relativ bald Ergebnisse geben.
So, was haben wir noch? Ähm es dreht sich ein bisschen der Wind.
Russland hat man so den Eindruck auch im russischen.
Fernsehen.
Ja. Also hier und da kommen jetzt auch äh mal Kritiker zur Sprache.
Die na ja so eine ich meine was heißt andere Meinung äh vertreten, also.
Ähm es gibt.
Auch in Russland gewisse Grenzen, was man nun sagen darf und was nicht, aber äh ja innerhalb dieser Grenzen scheint aber durchaus auch Kritik.
Möglich äh zu sein, beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich auch so äh äh gewollt zu sein oder geduldet zu sein jetzt mittlerweile
So und ähm da gab es halt dann so verschiedene Kommentatoren, aber.
Jetzt besonders interessant war das von einem äh ehemaligen russischen Oberst äh Michael äh auch.
Hodoranik äh heißt der, glaube ich genau oder also je nachdem da verschiedene Transiterationen.
Und das bemerkenswerte äh an seiner Kritik also was er im Fernsehen erstmal gesagt.
Hatte war äh dass er dass er eben auch gesagt hat okay Mobilmachung,
macht jetzt gerade keinen Sinn, weil hm wenn wir jetzt mobil machen, haben wir nix was wir den Soldaten an modernen Waffen in die Hand geben können und im,
die Soldaten dann mit Waffen aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg äh.
In die Ukraine zu schicken, wo sie auf eine äh mit moderner Doktrin und modernen Waffen kämpfende, ukrainische Armee stoßen
ähm hilft halt nicht äh irgendwie Erfolge militärische Erfolge äh zu.
Erzielen, so das hatte er halt jetzt im Fernsehen gesagt und.
Ein Kommentator bemerkte dann äh noch einen amerikanischer General, das äh Huderanik Huda Ranok so. Hm.
Anfang Februar einen Artikel veröffentlicht hat in,
russischen Medien auf Russisch, der wirklich der Hammer.
Ist so. Der wirklich auf den Punkt.
Genau äh vorhergesagt hat, was passieren würde.
Ja? Also wäre ich Putin äh den Mann, würde ich sofort als General einstellen oder sagen wir mal, nein, nicht wäre ich Putin, sondern wäre ich irgendwie regierender äh in in in Russland
so, das wäre irgendwie einfach mein Mann
weil also der ist der ist so gut äh dass ich da jetzt eigentlich äh ja ein paar Passagen aus äh einfach vorlesen möchte. Also die deutsche Übersetzung äh zumindest,
weil also.
Ähm der Artikel äh Titel ist Vorhersagen, Blutdrünstiger äh Politologen.
So und äh Untertitel von begeisterten Falken und hastigen Kuckucken. Ähm so ähm ja und äh dort, wie gesagt.
Vier Wochen vor dem Krieg äh.
Schreibt er darüber, ja, einige Vertreter der russischen politischen Klasse argumentieren heute, dass Russland in der Lage ist.
Der Ukraine in wenigen Stunden und kürzere Zeiträume werden auch genannt, eine vernichtende Niederlage zuzufügen, wenn ein militärischer Konflikt ausbricht. Mal sehen, wie solche Aussagen der Realität entsprechen.
Und.
Dann ja ja und mächtiger, russischer Feuerschlag, so wird alle Überwachungs- und Kommunikationssysteme Artillerie und Panzerverbände zerstören und äh
äh selbst ein vernichtender Schlag aus Russland ausreichen wird, um einen Krieg.
Solchen Krieg zu beenden, dass man sogar noch nicht mal mit Panzern rein müsste so. Und außerdem betonen einige Analysten, dass niemand in der Ukraine das Regime verteidigen werde, so.
Und dann ja, da beginnen wir mit dem Letzten.
Ähm zu behaupten, dass niemand in der Ukraine das Regime verteidigen werde, bedeutet in der Praxis völlige Ignoranz der militärpolitischen Lage und der Stimmung der breiten Volksmasten im Nachbarstaat. Darüber wird das,
Darüber hinaus wird das Ausmaß des Hasses.
Der, wie Sie wissen, der wirksamste Treibstoff für bewaffneten Kampf sind. In der Nachbarrepublik gegenüber Moskau offen unterschätzt. Niemand wird die russische Armee in der Ukraine mit Brot, Salz und Blumen treffen.
So ja äh ja begrüßen, genau.
Es scheint, dass die Ergebnisse im Südosten der Ukraine im Jahr 2014 niemanden etwas gelehrt haben. Schließlich erwarteten sie auch, dass die gesamte Linksuf-Rege,
in einem einzigen Impuls und in Sekundenschnelle Novous Russia verwandeln würde
verwandelt würde.
Wir haben bereits Landkarten gezeichnet, das Personal zukünftiger Verwaltungen von Städten und Regionen ausgerechnet und staatsflaggen entwickelt. Ähm.
Aber selbst die russischsprachige Bevölkerung dieses Teils der Ukraine einschließlich Städte wie Saporisch, Mariopol unterstützt solche Pläne in ihrer großen Mehrheit nicht.
Projekt Novorussia wurde irgendwann unmerklich weggeblasen und starb leise. So, der.
Und dann zitiert da noch irgendwie äh Arkadi Gaider mit, es ist klar, dass wir jetzt keinen leichten, sondern einen harten Kampf haben werden.
So und dann räumt er
dann im nächsten Abschnitt so ein bisschen ein, das irgendwie dieser mächtige Feuerschlag äh der irgendwie praktisch alle Überwachungs- und Kommunikationssysteme und Panzerverbände und Artillerie zerstören werde.
Dass das äh halt Politikergequatsche ist. Also er sagt, allein dieser Ausdruck zeigt, dass nur Politiker so etwas sagen können so. Also erstens meint er.
Das irgendwie äh einem mächtigen Feuerschlag gibt es im militärischen Jargon nicht, so Feuerangriffe äh äh können.
Halt ähm ja entweder massiv Gruppen oder Einzelangriffe sein, aber nicht mächtig, mittel oder schwach oder so, ja? Ähm.
Und ähm ja
Deswegen sagt er, okay, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, was äh ist denn jetzt ein massiver Feuerschlag und dann sagt er, okay, also erstmal Feuerschläge können halt im Rahmen der Front erfolgen, also von der Front.
Äh aus, die noch nicht existiert oder eben irgendwie innerhalb des des
Einsatzgebietes, wobei er dann auch noch sagt, es gibt gar kein Oberkommando, der Streitkräfte im Einsatzgebiet äh bisher, was dann ja auch erst mal noch sechs Wochen im Krieg andauerte, das fand ich dann auch noch mal bemerkenswert. So.
Und dann sagt er schlicht einfach äh ja.
So einen, so einen massiver Schlag wird dem potenziellen Feind schwere Verluste zufügen, aber zu erwarten, dass die Streitkräfte eines ganzen Staates mit nur einem solchen Schlag,
vernichtet werden können, nennt der schlichtweg ungezügelten Optimismus bei der Planung und Durchführung von Kampfhandlungen. So äh sondern und man müsse halt irgendwie auf,
alle Dinge gucken und äh insbesondere halt,
sagt er dann auch, ja, dass in den russischen Streitkräften es an
hochpräziven Waffenmangel, Hyperschallraketen von
Typ Zirkon sind noch nicht im Einsatz. Die Kaliber und die Kinnsalze, die luftgestützten Marschflugkörpers, äh,
haben hat Russland nur ein paar hundert oder.
Paar Dutzend im Fall von von Kinsalz und das Arsenal reicht absolut nicht aus, um einen Start von der Größe Frankreichs mit über 40 Millionen Einwohnern vom Erdboden zu vernichten,
und äh ja so und dann äh sagt er noch okay zur Luft zum Thema Luftüberlegenheit also erstens.
In Ländern, wo Russland Luftüberlegenheit.
Hat das jetzt nicht wirklich geholfen, also im Afghanistan hatten sie Luft,
Überlegenheit und die Gegner hatten kein einziges Flugzeug und keinen einzigen Kampfhubschrauber und trotzdem zog sich der Krieg zehn Jahre hin und die Tschetschenen hatten auch kein einziges Flugzeug und haben auch mehrere Jahre äh
gekämpft und dann sagt er, na ja und die Streitkräfte der Ukraine haben noch Kampfflugzeuge und äh eben Mittel zur Luftabwehr und
äh die äh die ukrainischen Besatzungen äh der Flugabwehrraketen seien zweitausend,
äh auch schon ziemlich gut gewesen und hätten der russischen Luftwaffe extreme Probleme äh bereitet und äh ihr damals schon schockierende Verluste beigefügt und das sollte man nicht vergessen.
So um ein Teer dann noch ja und ähm im Übrigen so ja.
Ja dann so.
Zustand der äh Streitkräfte der Ukraine sei äh ja angeblich in einem beklagenswerten Zustand, würde er ja immer irgendwie hören, aber davon ähm äh,
das da da ging er auch von vornherein davon aus, dass das überhaupt nicht äh so ist, sondern dass die Ukraine sehr wohl, sehr gut aufgestellt ist und ähm auch wenn sie leicht unterliegen sind, da haben sie also trotzdem doch noch äh
einiges zu bieten um den Russen irgendwie Probleme zu bereiten ne.
Und dann zitiert er auch nochmal irgendwie Alex äh verachte niemals deinen Feind, betrachte ihn nicht als dümmer und schwächer als dich, so
und äh dann äh ja sagt er dazu, okay
zu der Behauptung, dass die westlichen Länder keinen einzigen Soldaten in den Tod für die Ukraine schicken werden.
Da sagt er, ja, wahrscheinlich werden sie keine Soldaten schicken. So, aber
hat er im Falle einer russischen Invasion schließt es jedoch keineswegs eine massive Unterstützung der Streitkräfte der Ukraine durch den kollektiven Westen mit einer Vielzahl von Waffen
militärischer Ausrüstung sowie Massenlieferungen aller Art von Material aus. In dieser Hinsicht hat der Westen bereits eine bisher beispiellos so gefestigte Position gezeigt, die anscheinend in Moskau nicht vorhergesagt wurde.
So. Es besteht kein Zweifel, dass die Vereinigten Staaten und die Länder dann.
NATO eine Art Reinkarnation von nach dem Vorbild des zweiten Weltkriegs beginnen werden. Ja.
Darin besteht kein Zweifel. Ein Zuzug von Freiwilligen.
Zustrom von Freiwilligen aus dem Westen kann ich ausgeschlossen werden so. Also mit anderen Worten er beschreibt hier exakt aber wirklich so aufn Punkt genau, was dann passiert ist seitdem.
Also so vollständig komplett genau exakt genau das Ding.
Dann genau, dann sagt er noch was und irgendwie dann noch das Thema Partisanen äh und so äh und erobere die Stadt äh mit einem Luftregimment in zwei Stunden, ist bereits zu einem Klassiker des Genres geworden und auch das hat sich dann,
Ich beweide, die haben's trotzdem versucht mit Kiew und haben da ja die äh komplette Fallschirmjägerbataillone äh verloren. Ähm.
So ja und äh
ja dann auch, dass eben selbst der Mächtige stalinistische NKWD und die Sowjetarmee mehr als zehn Jahre lang ging.
Den nationalistischen Untergrund in der Westukraine gekämpft haben, so.
Und jetzt gibt es eine Option, dass die ganze Ukraine leicht in den Kampf gehen kann. So, darüber hinaus könnte diese Formation bereits auf dem Territorium Russlands leicht zu operieren beginnen. So.
Und dann sagt er noch auch, der bewaffnete Kampf in ukrainischen Großstädten ist im Allgemeinen schwer vorhersehbar äh und es ist bekannt, dass die Großstadt das beste Schlachtfeld für schwache und technisch weniger fort,
eine Seite des bewaffneten Konflikts ist und so und dass man eben, ja, er sagt dann auch noch mal Städtekampf äh wird
auch ganz ganz schlecht. So und außerdem so äh in der Ukraine gibt es irgendwie mehr als genug Großstädte auf solche mit,
einer Million Einwohnern und so können die russische Armee im Verlauf eines Krieges mit der Ukraine auf mehr.
Nur Stalingrad und Grozeny äh treffen.
Und äh dann äh sagt er äh.
Auch noch ähm ja also Blitzkrieg wird nichts, ganz klar. Vergesst Blitzkrieg
und dann meint er noch zum Schluss, dass ein bewaffneter Konflikt mit der Ukraine nicht im nationalen Interesse Russlands
äh liegt und sagt dann irgendwie ja einige überdrehte russische Experten sollten doch ihre Hassfantasien vergessen
und äh eben auch um weiteren Reputationsverlusten vorzubeugen äh nie wieder an Sie erinnern, ja.
Wieder erwähnen, ja. So aber äh also mit anderen Worten.
Da war jemand in Russland, der irgendwie genau.
Geschrieben hat oder oder einfach bescheid wusste. Aber ähm ja.
Auf den ganz offensichtlich dann zumindest Putin äh nicht gehört hat. Aber äh.
So, was dieser Artikel einfach zeigt, ist, äh er hätte es wissen können, ja, das ist äh sozusagen,
Das ist äh also das zeigt dieser Artikel, dass die Russen nicht alle nur Idioten und und und Vollpfosten sind, sondern dass es da auch Leute gibt,
die einfach mitdenken können und die realistisch äh Dinge auch einschätzen können, aber äh das sind halt nicht die, die dort grade die Entscheidungen treffen, aber
ja interessanter Einblick finde ich der mich wirklich weggehauen hat und auch.
Ja also selbst im Westen hat das niemand so,
in der Form, also so präzise eingeschätzt, selbst der Westen wusste nicht so genau, wie er sich verhalten würde, wie halt dieser.
Russische Oberste, also wirklich Chapeau. Äh ja.
Ja, jetzt gibt es äh noch Gerüchteküche. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern man da überhaupt drauf eingehen sollte, aber.
Das reißt ja irgendwie nicht ab so dieses Gerücht ist irgendwie Putin. Ähm.
Medizinische Probleme hat so und bei solchen Informationen muss man ja immer sehr aufpassen.
Weil man nie genau weiß, wo das jetzt eigentlich raus tickert und aus welchem Grund das irgendwie raus sickert, sondern an wen äh das jetzt irgendwie ein Signal ist, ob das irgendwie nur so eine Wurst ist.
Die den Medien im Westen zu fressen gegeben wird oder ob das tatsächlich äh interne Informationen sind, die einfach rausgeraten, weil irgendjemand,
was weiß ich damit beabsichtigen will aber gibt durchaus solche Berichte dass er,
krank ist, dass er irgendwie an Blutkrebs erkrankt sei,
dass er irgendwie auf seinen Reisen immer von Spezialärzten begleitet wird, die auch für solche Fälle
sind, dann wird irgendwie auch schon seinen Gang analysiert. Also er läuft irgendwie komisch, äh bewegt irgendwie nur den einen Arm dabei, also das ist natürlich schon nachvollziehbare Dinge. Da kann man dann seine eigenen
ähm Schlüsse draus ziehen, aber äh.
Kann auch darauf hinweisen, dass es irgendwie Rückenprobleme hat, was sehr wohl auch irgendwie auf dieses Krankheitsbild äh passen würde.
Und ähm ja äh
Das geht dann bis hin zu seinem leicht aufgeblasenen Gesicht. Ich meine, das kann man auch wie auch auf anderem Wege äh bekommen.
Interessant fand ich dann am Schluss hier noch in dieser einen Sache, äh könnte also auch alles darauf hinweisen, dass er irgendwie
irgendwie Blutkrebs entgegenzuwirken, so Steroide äh nimmt und ähm.
Als Seiteneffekte unter anderem auch so das Bild irgendwie, dass man dann äh vertieft irrational und paranoides äh Verhalten an den Tag legt.
Ja mein, ja die ist Thema Gesundheit äh des des Herrschers ist natürlich äh ja klassisch
äh und ähm deswegen, ich meine, die Amerikaner hatten ja,
im kalten äh Krieg dann auch einen erfolgreichen Angriff auf die Toilettenanlage in einem Hotel gefahren, wo sie dann äh die.
Ja äh die Scheiße des äh damals äh
russischen äh General äh Sekretärs, ich glaube Grußschaft war's äh dann erfolgreich abgegriffen haben und dann untersucht haben und dann auch festgestellt haben, dass er unter anderem wie Krebs hat.
Äh weshalb äh der amerikanische Präsident auch ja immer mit einer eigenen Toilette
nur ins Ausland verreist, also der amerikanische Präsident darf nicht einfach irgendwo ins Klo kacken.
Sondern das ist also der Code des amerikanischen Präsidenten ist Staatsgeheimnis.
Heilig.
So.
Genau äh diesen,
Gründen und äh wenn da gibt's dann immer irgendwie im Hotel wird dann halt speziell eine Toilette für ihn installiert, auf die er dann äh dann gehen darf und wo dann nichts irgendwie ins ins.
Äh System geht oder irgendjemand dann das analysieren könnte.
Was jetzt Putin angeht? Also ich finde.
So jetzt unabhängig von von von Berichten, wenn ich mir jetzt angucke, sieht der für mich jetzt auch nicht tottiger aus äh als jetzt Biden oder Trump,
So, ja so jetzt nur auf den ersten Blick. Ich meine, das sind alles äh keine keine jungen,
Leute mehr aber klar natürlich für für Putin ist das natürlich besonders wichtig und er sah auch tatsächlich nicht nicht gut aus aber ich hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl was auch immer er jetzt hat,
äh dass Ihnen das jetzt in dem Maße beeinträchtigen würde, dass er jetzt nicht mehr in der Lage ist ähm ja zu funktionieren.
Das das denke ich.
Da habe ich schon gesehen, das war,
also ich meine manchmal werden ja irgendwie Länder von so Leuten äh regiert hier äh wie hieß noch der Vogel, den Simbabwe Mugabe, also der war ja auch,
am Schluss zu zu gar nichts mehr zu gebrauchen. Aber hat sich also wirklich bis an seinen letzten Tag noch irgendwie an der Macht gehalten. Na ja, so funktioniert das halt. Ich äh will jetzt auch gar nicht damit sagen, dass es ähm.
So ist, sondern dass das so Teil der öffentlichen Diskussion und Wahrnehmung ist, dass so was halt herumgeschoben wird und es ist sehr schwierig ist, dem in irgendeiner Form jetzt äh Wahrheit oder Bedeutung gar.
Zuzuschieben und unter Umständen gehört das einfach auch nur zur allgemeinen Verwirrung und Kriegspropaganda. Äh was auch immer man damit bezwecken möchte, aber es kann natürlich auch durchaus sein
dass sich äh Widerstände innerhalb des russischen Machtkomplexes äh langsam formieren. Man weiß es nicht.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wenn man, wenn man sich einfach nur durchliest, welche auf der Wikipedia Seite, welche
Krankheiten, Hitler alles zugeschrieben wurden
äh so von psychischen also dreißig, 40 verschiedene psychische Krankheiten, je nachdem immer was grade eben in war, äh so in dem Bereich und dann natürlich alle möglichen organischen
Erkrankung wahrscheinlich ja irgendwas wird wird dran äh sein, also es gibt.
Muss das jetzt nicht alles alles abtun, aber äh die Frage ist natürlich immer äh so,
inwieweit ist das jetzt tatsächlich entscheidend äh so
für das was was passiert so inwieweit beeinflusst das jetzt den den weiteren Verlauf und da
ja finde ich finde ich schwierig zu sagen daraus jetzt äh irgendwelche Schlüsse
zu ziehen aus jetzt möglicherweise organischen Erkrankungen dar.
Denke ich sind seine grundsätzlichen Überzeugungen, die er ja auch in den letzten Jahren geäußert hat, reichen da vollkommen aus, um sein Verhalten im Moment äh zu verstehen.
Sage ich mal.
Kommen wir dann vielleicht zum Ende äh auch noch mal auf ein mögliches äh Ende. Wie sieht's denn jetzt so aus? Also,
Alle wollen natürlich, dass das vorbei ist, deswegen ist es immer sehr leicht, sich an an alle möglichen Nachrichten ranzuklemmen und zu sagen, das ist jetzt ein klares Indiz dafür, äh dass es bald vorbei ist, aber,
mehren sich schon so ein wenig die Einschätzungen die sagen am Ende ist das jetzt nichts was irgendwie die nächsten fünf Jahre lang wird. Ich meine das haben wir bei Corona auch gesagt ähm.
Also interessant in dem Zusammenhang ist äh sagen sich einfach mal beide Seiten
anzugucken, weil natürlich ein Frieden nur dann funktioniert, wenn beide Seiten irgendwie zu der Erkenntnis kommen, äh dass eine Fortführung äh.
Jetzt ja schlechter ist äh als ähm ja ein Waffenstillstand unter den aktuellen Bedingungen. Und.
Ähm wenn man sie jetzt erstmal die Ukraine äh anschaut, dann äh war das so, dass,
ja am Anfang, glaube ich, in den ersten zwei, drei Wochen gab es dann durchaus die Bereitschaft der Ukraine äh zu sagen, okay, äh
für den Frieden, also für einen schnellen Frieden oder Waffenstillstand, werden wir durchaus auch bereit, irgendwelche territorialen Konzessionen.
Zu machen, ja. Das war,
So also wir können über alles reden so. Wir werden sicherlich nichts dauerhaft abtreten, aber sagen über den Status äh und und so äh ja.
Aber das hat sich mittlerweile jetzt gewandelt. Einmal natürlich.
Aufgrund der bereits erbrachten Opfer und Zerstörungen durch Russland und natürlich insbesondere dann den Kriegsverbrechen, die da passiert sind, äh.
Ist jetzt die Stimmung in der Ukraine, also äh,
unter Rückzug auf Vorinvasionslinien läuft gar nichts.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen das absolute äh Minimum, äh glaube ich, was jetzt äh wo auch Selensky in der Lage wäre ähm,
oder willens wäre, äh dass eben zu verkaufen auch auch in der.
In der Ukraine ja. Also drunter äh geht's nicht, aber mittlerweile hm so wie die strategische Situation.
Jetzt für die Ukraine aussieht, sieht's halt eher so aus, dass Russland tendenziell schwächer wird äh und.
Die Ukraine tendenziell stärker. So das heißt äh trotz der ganzen.
Opfer natürlich, Öl spielt die Zeit im Moment,
eher für die Ukraine und das weiß die Ukraine auch und deswegen ist halt jetzt erklärtes äh Kriegsziel äh die Russen äh,
komplett aus dem Land zu vertreiben. Was die Krim angeht äh,
ja äh ist die Stimmung in der Ukraine zumindest bei vielen auch so, dass sie die Krim jetzt auch wieder haben wollen.
Dass sie jetzt äh da,
ist dann so ein bisschen eben gibt's dann im Westen von amerikanischer Seite so ein bisschen Vorbehalte noch, ob man äh das wirklich will, weil die,
sozusagen, weil Russland ja
die Ukrain äh äh die die Krim als russisches Staatsgebiet jetzt betrachtet und das Ganze äh sagen als Angriff auf russisches Staatsgebiet.
Äh oder als Invasion in russisches Staatsgebiet sehen könnte und dass das dann halt zu einer Eskalation führen könnte, aber.
Am Ende äh betont halt.
Auch die USA, das ist letztlich eine Entscheidung der Ukrainer, ja. Wir.
Werden äh also die Ukraine muss sagen, wenn's genug ist. Ja so das ist das ist die Haltung jetzt der einen Seite.
Bei den Russen ähm ja ist.
Wahrscheinlich das das Ziel irgendwo ähm man da das war jetzt auch schon ganz schön teuer, hat halt eine Menge gekostet und.
Deswegen möchte man natürlich einen einen Deal jetzt, wo man möglichst viel Land noch dazu bekommen,
so und dann einen Rückzug auf alte Position scheint derzeit aber auch nicht nicht wirklich.
Denkbar zu sein. Dazu ähm ist dann die Position Russlands, jetzt ist die militärische Position Russlands noch zu gut.
So, das heißt ähm dann Verhandlungen von beiden, also beide Seiten im Moment
wollen keine Fahndung, wobei der Eindruck so ein bisschen besteht, dass Putin sich zumindest,
den das Ganze jetzt offen halten möchte und jetzt nicht versucht ähm sich unnötig Türen äh zu verbauen. Also er weiß, dass auch irgendwann mhm.
Dieser Krieg beendet werden muss. So.
Und äh dass das Ergebnis nicht eine komplette Übernahme der Ukraine sein wird, ist ihm jetzt, glaube ich
auch klar geworden so. Ja das heißt, das sind glaube ich die Parameter, unter denen er operiert und er geht davon aus, äh jetzt äh er versucht, so viel Land wie möglich
zu gewinnen noch und dann irgendeinem Punkt äh dann zu sagen okay, dann lass uns jetzt mal ernsthaft
reden und aber bis dahin eben eine möglichst gute Verhandlungsposition zu haben, nur,
müsste sich dazu auch seine Verhandlungsposition verbessern und das hat sie sich im letzten Monat nicht
wirklich, sondern sie hat sich eher tendenziell leicht verschlechtert äh würde ich sagen. Over overall äh wie's wie's aussieht.
Und ähm ansonsten ist aber dieser Konflikt,
noch weit entfernt davon sagen zu einem Konflikt zu werden, also der ist definitiv äh alles andere als frozen, sondern geht eben grade mit hoher Intensität.
Weiter, wo klar ist, dass sich der in dieser Intensität
Licht wird fortsetzen lassen. Man sieht es ja an einigen Fronten auch schon, wo dann relativ Ruhe eingekehrt sind, weil einfach beide Seiten.
Gerade nicht so versessen äh sind auf auf Kampf im im Moment, aber,
das gilt halt nicht für die nicht für alle Fronten und einigen Fronten ähm haben wir wahrscheinlich jetzt durchaus Gefechte äh oder eine Intensität, die
dem entspricht, was im Zweiten Weltkrieg äh so auch gelaufen ist an.
In sehr viel kürzerer Zeit, muss man dazu sagen. Also ich äh für mich sieht es so aus Russland wäre jetzt ganz froh, wenn sie äh Jazzon.
Könnten, diesen ganzen äh Streifen, Landstreifen von der Krim am Asophschen Meer über Mario Pool hin bis zu Donetsk und äh Luhansk.
Im Prinzip noch dieses äh Spirit äh fehlt. Sehr viel mehr scheint.
Nicht mehr drin zu sein. Also große Vorstöße, Einkesselung et cetera.
Äh und das ist so ein bisschen der aktuelle Zustand und es könnte jetzt sein
dass wir jetzt so ein militärisches Kippen beobachten können. Im Prinzip haben wir es schon, um in so und je nachdem, wie gut
Ukraine jetzt ihre äh dort gewonnenen Vorteile ausspielt und es in irgendeiner Form schafft, an die Versorgungslinien ranzugehen oder überhaupt generell hinter die Linien zu kommen, durch die neuen Haubitzen und ähm ähnliche Waffen.
Und weitere Schwächungen natürlich der Russen glaube ich.
Wie du's ja auch schon gesagt hast, also ich glaube, dass die Ukraine daran glaubt, dass sie in der Lage sind, die Russen noch weiter zu schwächen und die werden einfach Probleme haben, diese ganzen gewonnenen Gebiete zu halten. Zumindest im Osten.
Im Süden müsse halt die Ukraine sich selbst noch mal äh verstärken. Keine Ahnung wie jetzt die
Lieferungen verteilt werden und wo sie jetzt ihre äh Prioritäten setzen, das wird man dann halt äh sehen. Aber sie sind bisher relativ intelligent vorangegangen. Sie haben die Möglichkeiten. Sie kriegen eine Verstärkung äh des Militärs.
In allen Fähigkeiten,
ja, was die Aufklärung betrifft, was Angriff betrifft, was Verteidigung betrifft. Wir hatten ja vorhin die Liste allein der Amerikaner, das ist ja noch lange nicht alles. Da kommen ja Lieferungen überall aus Europa, aus Australien, et cetera und das wird auch so weitergehen.
Einfach weil jetzt irgendwie der Wespen beschlossen hat, Russland muss besiegt werden und im Prinzip kämpft.
Ukraine, mit ihren Fähigkeiten der NATO oder zumindest mit einem Teil der Fähigkeiten der NATO ähm und dem Arsonal,
äh gegen Russland und so wie unser Militärexperte da äh das im Februar schon erklärt hat äh ja das liegt alles schon nicht mehr im Interesse Russlands.
Parallel dazu läuft immer noch weiter eine permanente Verschärfung der Sanktionen und ähm.
Wenn eben manche Länder nicht unbedingt dem Westen jetzt so ohne Weiteres äh beispringen werden. Ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass sich jetzt alle besonders drum bemühen, Russland den Rücken zu sterben zu stärken.
Ja, also das ist halt eher so ein ein verhaltener Support.
Ja
Also auch äh sagen, was wohl aus China äh da gekommen ist, äh ist äh ja auch eher enttäuschend, also äh so selbst.
Soweit ich das mitbekommen habe ist dieses chinesische Bezahlsystem.
Was da in die Bresche gesprungen ist sie haben sich wieder zurückgezogen aus
Russland ja also diese Kreditkarten Ersatz für westliche Kreditkarten, die man die Russen haben immer noch ihre eigenen Systeme und so.
Aber ja, selbst an der Front äh glaube ich, möchten die Chinesen gerade nicht unbedingt Geschäfte mit Russland machen und der Punkt,
ist halt auch, dass ja Russland zumindest als Außenhandelspartner für China relativ unbedeutend ist.
So und äh dass sie halt dann eher durch also Chinesen äh
da spielt Geld gerade auch einfach eine große Rolle und die haben eigentlich keine Lust jetzt äh für Russlands Krieg mit zu bezahlen.
Ja ähm sondern auch aus Chinas Sicht
ist es natürlich nicht so schlecht, wenn Russland jetzt geschwächt wird, weil im Grunde genommen.
Ja sind.
Verbindet Russland und China auch eine langjährige Rivalität und der einzige Grund, warum die jetzt grade so miteinander äh.
Können. Äh es halt, weil's beides grade relativ totalitäre Systeme sind, wobei das in Russland eher totalitärer ist und sich da
schon mit seiner seiner Partei rumschlagen muss. Äh also im größeren Ausmaß denke ich.
Und äh ja, also bis bislang sagt steht,
also stehen die Länder nicht gerade Schlange, jetzt Russland zu unterstützen. Ein oder andere wird irgendwie vielleicht ein gucken können, so jetzt etwas billiger an an Öl zu kommen oder.
China dann auch wie.
Gucken einen guten Gaststil zu kriegen äh jetzt aber im Grunde genommen ja äh.
Ist da auch China mehr oder weniger eine No-Show, was auch eine große Erleichterung für die Amerikaner äh war, weil das war ja so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass da.
China jetzt einspringen äh äh könnte und den Russen irgendwie unter die Arme greifen, aber danach sieht's im Moment gar nicht aus.
Ja und wenn man jetzt mal noch abschließend vielleicht.
In die Weite Ferne äh guckt, nämlich ähm.
Was denn jetzt die Folgen für Russland eigentlich sein könnten oder sollten ähm bin ich auf einen äh,
ja interessanten Dokumentationsbeitrag gestoßen, der ganz gut,
argumentiert, dass es eigentlich für Russland nur einen wirklich positiven Ausgang geben kann, nämlich wenn es zerfällt,
So das klingt natürlich erstmal wie die Horrorvorstellung, oh mein Gott äh so, aber.
Ähm so er argumentiert da halt auch ganz schön, dass hm ja im Moment ist Russland halt Moskau.
So also oder Moskau ist halt alles und der Rest des Landes ist so ja ähm nicht nicht wirklich äh bedeutend so.
Ja oder also es gibt halt ganz, ganz viele Regionen, die ja sich auch nicht entwickeln können einfach unter.
Moskaus Dominanz. Natürlich trägt Moskau auch eine ganze Menge zum zum Ausgleich äh bei und in Sowjetzeiten hatte man ihm auch versucht,
die Produktion im Land so zu verteilen, dass alle voneinander abhängig sind, dass eben niemand sich so wirklich selbstständig
machen kann, was dann natürlich auch nochmal ein Riesenproblem war, als der die Sowjetunion zerfallen ist, dass er dann alles noch schlimmer gemacht, aber das ist wohl heute teilweise
eben eben auch noch äh so und hm es herrscht aber gleichzeitig eben,
auch wohl tatsächlich einen Ethnozentrismus äh in der Moskauer Bevölkerung. Es ist zwar nicht so offen, rassistisch, aber wenn man dann ein bisschen tiefer guckt, stellt man halt dann schon fest, dass die Russen
eigentlich sich als etwas Besseres sehen als jetzt ich sage mal die
nicht Russen, so die ganzen ja äh Bevölkerung in den Stars und die ganzen Muslime und also auch da,
gibt es ähm.
Ja einen zumindest sagen einen unterschwelligen Rassismus äh und einen unterschwelligen ja natürlich auch oder oder einen klaren Führungsanspruch, dass man selber es die Russen
wissen, was am besten ist auch für diese Völker. So und ähm ja, wenn man äh aber dann.
Auch sieht, wie Russland denn jetzt mit der Ukraine umgeht, die ja angeblich auch irgendwie wir alle Verwandte sind und eigentlich auch wieder Teil von Russland äh sein
äh soll, kann man sich halt ganz gut vorstellen oder oder sieht man halt, dass
äh ja dieser russische Föderalismus äh dann nicht wirklich ein echter Föderalismus
äh ist oder eben einen sehr zentralisierter Föderalismus. Im Gegensatz.
Zu Deutschland beispielsweise und da das eine nette historische Beispiel, dass ja die Franzosen vor allem darauf bestanden haben, dass Deutschland eine starke föderale Struktur kriegt.
Damit äh es eben militärisch und politisch geschwächt.
Ist so damit sozusagen die Zentralregierung nicht nicht viel machen kann und deswegen äh haben wir halt
auch die Polizei äh Kräfte, die halt den Ländern unterstellt sind äh unter anderem und nur.
Stellte sich dann raus, dass das aber genau das richtige Rezept war so für Deutschland, dass Deutschland nun mal schon immer so ein bisschen viel Völkerstaat war und das einfach so eine föderale Struktur, wo,
halt es eben keine Zentrale gibt, die fürs ganze Land entscheidet, dann wesentlich mehr Zufriedenheit und Prosperität und vor allen Dingen ja wirtschaftliche Entwicklung.
Gebracht hat. Ähm als wenn man äh das Ganze jetzt zentralisiert hätte, so und.
Und das Argument ist eben auch, dass also Russland sagen, so solange Russland dieses
Russland ist in dieser russischen Föderation mit diesem starken Zentralismus, dass dort halt nie wirklich
Ruhe sein wird.
Und äh dass es sich eben auch wirtschaftlich sich die Region nicht so werden entwickeln äh können und dabei gibt es eben sehr, sehr viele Regionen auch in Russland, wenn die,
autonom wären und es halt äh irgendwie dann trotzdem Frieden gäbe ähm.
Wo äh ja Russland und die Russen in auch in Freiheit und Prosperität leben könnten und ich fand zumindest diese These.
Ähm ja hatte was für sich, wobei natürlich dahin zu kommen. Also wenn äh dann äh Russland wirklich zerfällt
äh so, das birgt natürlich unglaubliche Gefahren dann auch äh in sich und äh dürfte dann auch nicht äh wirklich friedlich ablaufen, so das ist das einzige Problem.
An der Sache. Aber ansonsten.
Sonst.
Aber ansonsten.
Ja.
Für die Leute, für Leute, aber wenn wenn sich dann mal berappelt haben, äh wär's eigentlich ganz, ganz super und im Grunde genommen äh lebt ja auch Russland jetzt durchaus mit mit
bestimmten ehemaligen Nachbarn dann doch in Frieden zumindest so.
Aber ähm ja.
Also alles, was ich so gehört habe.
Über den Zustand der russischen Gesellschaft und was wir hier auch schon so diskutiert haben, dann bin ich irgendwie relativ ähm pessimistisch, was so eine positive gesellschaftliche Entwicklung in den nächsten Jahren betrifft. Das ist ein Land, was einfach sich dermaßen unter.
Äh Einfluss von Propaganda äh befindet gerade, das das dauert lange und es gibt vor allem auch diese ganze.
Demokratische Tradition ist vielleicht jetzt ein etwas großes Wort. Die Erfahrung damit und.
Vor allem auch wenig positive Erfahrungen damit man kennt's nicht anders. Das ist so das, was ich sagen möchte. Und äh ob so ein Land sich da schnell in eine andere Richtung entwickeln kann. Das hat in Deutschland nur funktioniert, weil wir einfach.
Einerseits schon ein bisschen Vorgeschichte hatten, aber dann eben auch einfach der die Niederlage so total und spürbar und unausweichlich war. Und das wird ja so in diesem Krieg nicht stattfinden.
Ob es überhaupt gefühlt eine Niederlage für die Russen gibt, das hängt im Wesentlichen davon ab, was da äh im.
Fernsehen verkündet wird, ja? Also du kannst halt auch einfach sagen ähm die ganze Diskussion auch mit irgendwie ja, wir müssen irgendwie für Putin eine ein eine Option anbieten der Gesichtswahrung.
Vielleicht gar nicht erforderlich, weil da sowieso eine totale VR.
Findet und äh da wird dann einfach gesagt, ist es jetzt so und so. Am Ende sagt er einfach, wir haben gewonnen. Der Donbass ist unser, fertig.
Ja ähm ja grundsätzlich
stimmt das so? Also sein seine, seine Offroad äh kann er sich halt da zurecht basteln, äh äh wie er will, also wie es so schön heißt, nur das geht halt auch nur zu.
Gewissen äh in einem gewissen Maß in gewissen Grenzen. Mhm ein,
Szenario ist halt, dass jetzt Russland, beziehungsweise Putin halt das jetzt pushen und pushen und pushen und ähm,
Ja, äh trotzdem aber irgendwann an den Punkt kommen, wo hm die Ukraine,
eine solche militärische Übermacht hat, hm dass.
Das russische Militär regelrecht kollabiert. Das kann dann.
So durchaus schnell gehen, ja? Gut, die haben immer noch die Möglichkeit sich äh hinter die Grenze äh zurückzuziehen
und dann zu hoffen, dass die Ukrainer an der Grenze stehen bleiben. Ähm aber
das lässt sich natürlich dann schwierig verkaufen, wenn dann deine Armee am Ende, ich weiß nicht
50.000 Tote Soldaten äh oder hunderttausend Tote, Verwundete und Kriegsgefangene zusammen oder so.
Und die und die Hälfte des des äh der Ausrüstung.
Verloren und unzerstört. Das stößt halt dann auf Grenzen, das als Sieg zu verkaufen, so. Ähm ja und wie gesagt, wenn die russische Armee
zusammenbrechen sollte, was jetzt nicht vielleicht nicht das Wahrscheinlichste ist, aber ein mögliches Szenario, zumindest wenn.
Sie sich nicht rechtzeitig zurückziehen und dann na ja und dann die Sache noch mit der mit der Krim, also
ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass auch dann äh wieder die Ukraine dann erstmal den Russen auf der
Krim, solange es da keinen Friedensvertrag gibt äh irgendwann das Leben auch sehr unangenehm äh machen kann.
Mit entsprechender militärischer Übermacht und vor allem wenn dann auch noch ja die Luftwaffe sich dann weiter erholt und sich in sechs Monaten
sie dann auch irgendwie fünfzig, hundert oder 150 F 16 Tammflugzeug haben? Gut, sie werden nicht so viele Piloten haben, also insofern
aber ja ähm ich denke äh es gibt.
Ein Szenario, das nicht völlig unrealistisch ist, wo hm das russische Militär so was wie einen Kollaps erleidet.
Der den dann Putin auch nicht mehr schönreden kann. Ja.
Ja, das stimmt sicherlich. Also.
Wir sind jetzt noch ein bisschen weit weg von diesem möglichen Zustand. Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als könnte es so ein.
Das könnten wir so kurz vor so einem Tipping Point stehen. Kann auch sein, dass es noch ein paar Wochen.
Hinnes, aber was man auf jeden Fall sicher sagen kann, ist die Dynamik des Krieges.
Im Sinne von die Russen stoßen in ukrainisches Gebiet vor, was wir jetzt die letzten drei Monate quasi im Wesentlichen dokumentiert haben hier.
Die es zum Stillstand gekommen. Es gibt keine Dynamik mehr in diesem Krieg. Die Russen sind irgendwie
mehr oder weniger an den Positionen, wo sie jetzt sind, fest und was wir so an Bewegung sehen, bewegt sich so im 1hundert Meter pro Tag äh Bereich, wenn überhaupt
Aber da, wo es nach vorne geht, geht's auch mal wieder zurück. Also im Wesentlichen tut sich eigentlich gar nix.
So mit anderen Worten, wir sind so an so einem Punkt gekommen, wo jetzt einfach die Beschleunigung auf null ist und es kann jetzt eben sein, dass wir in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen so eine Gegenbewegung sehen. Vielleicht sehen wir sie schon da in Sharkiv,
vielleicht äh geht's jetzt auch erst richtig los. Vielleicht dauert's auch noch so ein bisschen. Aber äh es ist zumindest schon mal so ein Zustand, wo man auch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung kann, das haben kann, dass die,
Flüchtlingsströme zurückgehen, vielleicht auch mehr Leute zurückkehren und das äh ja äh ist ab jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen besser wird.
Also wäre ich,
jetzt ähm sagen in der Ukraine für die Taktik zuständig mit meinen eigens begrenzten Einblicken jetzt von hier aus äh würde ich erstmal sagen und,
denke, das machen die Ukraine auch, dass die sagen, gut, grundsätzlich äh brauchen wir.
Für einen Vormarsch oder um Enjoffensive zu gehen, einfach eine Übermacht, weil äh ohne Übermacht ähm ist eine Offensive zu verlustreich. So, das heißt, hm.
Sie werden halt auch weiter ihr behutsam vorgehen äh noch bis
sie eine Übermacht haben und werden erstmal versuchen weiter letztlich zu verteidigen und ein bisschen äh nach vorne zu verteidigen und
ein bisschen auch im Hinterland zu stören, aber ähm ich glaube nicht, dass wir in kürzerer Zeit.
Eine ukrainische Großoffensive äh sehen werden. Anders äh würde ich das,
so in zwei oder drei Monaten,
sehen, dann halte ich es durchaus für möglich, dass in dem Zeitraum spätestens bis zum Winter äh vor dem Winter äh die
Ukraine hm tatsächlich eine Stärke aufgebaut haben,
könnte, wo sie dann äh äh wirklich richtig in die Offensive äh gehen kann. Ja, also wo sie dann in
einigen Teilen eben nicht in der Unterzahl, sondern dann eben auch in doppelter oder dreifacher Überzahl ist äh und äh dann
wirklich in der Lage ist, weil ähm es den Russen ähm äh weil es den Ukrainern,
auch nicht an kampfwilligen Personal mangelt. Die können im Moment mhm haben sie glaube ich
eine halbe Million Leute mehr oder weniger, die sie äh noch in die Armee eingliedern könnten.
Und äh es dauert halt nur, die jetzt auszubilden und die zu bewaffnen, aber ja, äh im Zeitraum von einigen Monaten,
so
stehen alle Zeichen so, dass dass die Ukraine in der Lage sein könnte, eine Übermacht aufzubauen während äh Russland eben bestenfalls mhm.
Das halten kann äh an an Kampfkraft.
Äh was jetzt da ist, aber eben nicht in der Lage ist, jetzt noch mal großartig.
Ja ich würde sagen, dabei können wir uns jetzt erstmal äh belassen.
Joa.
Dann lassen wir das auch einfach mal dabei und sagen ähm vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören. Wir werden zu gegebener Zeit wieder mal ein Update äh zur Situation zusammenfegen.
Freuen uns auf eure äh Kommentare und ähm ja sagen tschüss.